the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the third leg of the grand chess tour
kicked off in glorious fashion at the
2022 super united rapid and blitz in
songwrit croatia top players from around
the globe sought to showcase their rapid
and blitz prowess while racking up
crucial tour points the event began with
the unprecedented news that reigning
world champion magnus carlson would not
be defending his world title sending the
chess world into a frenzy dutch
superstar jordan van forest quickly
showed that he is more than just a tour
wild card with an astounding showing in
the rapid portion propelling him to the
top of the standings going into the
blitz section despite an up and down
performance early on the world champion
probably proved why he is one of the
best players in history blazing through
his competition posting an incredible
plus five score without drawing to vault
to the top of the leaderboard going into
the final day despite an impressive run
by french phenom a larissa perugia the
magnus drain proved to be completely
unstoppable and ultimately uncatchable
as the sun set on the croatian capital
players looked west to st louis missouri
there they will battle it out on the
penultimate leg of the 2022 branches
tour the saint louis rapid and blitz
coming up next
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome everybody to day one of the
saint louis rapidom blitz the fourth
stop of the grand chess tour we are in
front of the gateway arch the biggest
arch in the world well we have the best
chess players in the world competing for
the saint louis rapid and bliss title
let's go to the studio and start today's
action with yasser and peter
but before we do that here's a shot of
the the outside of the
saint louis chess club with players
arriving for
their day's work blazing sunshine here
in saint louis very very nice weather if
you like it hot
and uh
the action is about to begin here in the
central west end hello i'm peter
swiddler and with me is
yazza sayron peter big big big hearty
welcome to saint louis lincoln
to call the action with you again thank
you thank you so what are you looking
forward to
i am looking forward to a great
tournament of rapid and blitz featuring
some of the best players in the world
speaking of which
who we're playing
what's our roster peter the lineup is
tremendously impressive
as you can see uh with hikaru leading
the field uh up there uh followed by
andy pomnishy who will play his uh
second world championship match and once
again we're back with the
uh
people getting wandered
at the club yeah a very very normal
normal scene these days at chess
tournaments but yeah back to back to our
field yanni palmer she will play his
second world championship match in as
many years right uh then fabi uh mbl uh
levon alireza shahriar
and nier all full tour participants and
uh sam shanklin and jeffrey shang
rounding off an extremely impressive and
very american heavy field indeed it is
and our format either
yeah the format is as as
usual with the rapid events in the gct
uh it's basically three round robins
wrapped into one all of them 10 round 10
10 play around robins first they start
with
rapid games of 25 plus 10 a kind of a
relaxed calm time control by today's
standards right blitz will be five plus
two no drawers at any point and the
scoring system as you can see rapid
counts double or two points for a win
one for a draw and in the blitz games
the usual scoring system of one point
for a win and half a point for a draw
applies
our entire schedule
and as for the schedule for for this
event it's extremely straightforward
they start today and they play until
tuesday every day
uh starting at the same time
three days of rapid three games per day
friday saturday and sunday and then two
full round robins of blitz on monday and
tuesday with potential playoffs on
tuesday and then the closing ceremony
the same day
excellent and we're very fortunate to
have in studio with us grand master
christian shirilla christian good to see
you drill down on this event and the
players themselves
it's great to be back in the studio with
two legends such as yourself casting the
games of the best chess players on the
planet we've had an amazing grand chess
tour up to this point so let's take a
look where we stand in terms of grand
chess tour standings we're going to see
a dominant wesley soul in the top
position with 22.5 grand chester points
he actually is not playing in this event
because he already played two rapid and
blitz events mvl levon aronian fabiano
caruana ali reza first yana pognashi and
lanier dominguez full-time tour
participants are playing in this event
also chakriar mamadiarov unfortunately
richie rapport was unable to travel due
to ongoing travel restrictions he tied
for ninth position in romania and
improved on his standing in poland
finished in sixth position he will be
unable to travel to the united states
and participate in the saint louis
rapidom blitz as well as the sinful cop
and he was replaced in this event by
grand master jeffrey strong and young up
and coming superstar from the united
states aged only 21. i mean i know
jeffrey since he was 10 years of age and
he was beating me even and at that age
this guy is just an amazing superstar
he's also the 2016 world junior chess
champion that's a huge title and another
player that will be participating in
this event as a wildcard is a man with a
legion of fans that is grand master
hikaru nakamura urs rating 28-15 and he
is also the defending champion he won in
2021 the saint louis rapid and blitz
needless to say we have so many strong
participants and the chess is just
simply going to be fantastic thank you
christian and indeed uh every round is
going to feature great matchups
absolutely do the honors lay the table
what do you have for us for round one
let's take a look at the pairings for
the first round we have jeffrey on the
white side against young fabi is playing
white against sam shankland
ligniere is white against hikaru alireza
ferrugia is white against and jarov and
there at the bottom you see the i think
that the pairing of the round
for sure yeah
and uh as as christian correctly stated
uh wesley is currently leading in the
tour standings but with the tournament
in hand
both livon and mbl
uh could overtake him if they finish i
think basically just finishing in the
top half of the tournament that should
be enough
and let's jump to tony rich
who's standing by to welcome everybody
for round one
hello everyone and welcome to the
playing hall it's the temporary playing
hall but we have the very best chess
players in the world sitting down
settling in and getting ready for the
first round of play over the next five
days they'll compete in three days of
rapid two days of blitz chess to see who
the ultimate winner of the st louis
rapidom blitz is back to you guys in the
studio
well well thank you for that tony
somehow i expected more of a welcoming
everybody we're happy it was a very nice
shot though for me personally because i
i saw that i will be able to discuss
some cricket with people here because
there was sunil there in the shot i i
picked up on that as well west indies
and
there we have our uh very young ali
rousseau getting ready for battle i was
about to say that in these five days
that are coming up we're going to see a
lot of fighting and what are they
fighting for
absolutely
yeah let's take a look at a handsome one
let's take a look at that the price fund
for uh the rapid and blitz tournaments
in the gct is as it was in the first to
175
000
total with 40 grand up top and as you
can see there 12 13 points for the
winner depending on whether you win it
outright or if you die for first
30 for second 25 for uh for third and
going all the way down to
uh seven thousand dollars for the last
place finish and the whole point is of
those grand chess tour points the top
three finishers is a very very handsome
pool of money uh it's not only you know
you get the bragging rights of winning
and being a grand chester champion but
also
an extra 100 000 in cash absolutely you
see mvl getting ready um we haven't
talked about it yet but it's something
we have to uh
your predictions predictions for
already yesterday already
before round one i think we should get
this in yeah we should probably before
before the game start would be a good
time yeah okay peter as your uh honored
guest we're gonna let you go first i'm
going to take
yeah
i think jan's uh you know in a very rich
way in vain of form and i think uh he
will he will probably enjoy playing
rapid and blitz potentially more than he
will he will enjoy playing the the the
second event because it allows him sort
of more freedom of expression so i'm
[Applause]
and we'll just stand by with our
predictions for the reigning of the bell
with jeannie dr jeannie siegfield and
she will be doing the honors to start
event there you see our young
[Music]
there there she is uh dr jeanne singfeld
uh about to
let this ship sail exactly
or have you uh done the ring
before
i've never done it myself i've i've hit
it gone
i i've done this once the players so i'm
gonna hate it i'm not gonna lie
at the sound of the bell please go ahead
and start white's clock
that is that's a serious very nice ring
yeah that's a serious well well done
well done dr ginny yeah and we have we
have moves coming in as you can see
levon starting with the horse move
in game one which is a very solid move
yeah very solid i'm more fascinated by
the sure yeah myself the color of the
shirt in a way yeah it's it's very nice
to see one back uh you know not to not
to criticize the the administrative
choices the us and the olympic team made
in in playing in in uniform i'll be
critical yeah but
specifically for levon i think it was
perhaps one of the underlying factor
factors for for his
uh less than stellar performance i think
you will agree with this society yeah
exactly yeah and now he's back in in his
uh
you know very very nice tropical type
yeah
continuing our conversation i'm going to
jump in and i'm going to say hikaru her
car is the defending champion and once
you become a fan of the stream and see
how he
plays so
easily and quickly these blitz and rapid
events i can't help but making him a
huge favorite and jump right in
christian what are you who's your pick i
will have to go with ali reza ferrugia
for uh
i think a lot of weight got off his
shoulders after the candidates event and
he's been starting to play a lot of
tournaments after that he just finished
the ftx crypto cup in miami he's not jet
lagged he's been in the united states
for quite a long time and he's
definitely starting to find his tribe
i'm going to go with ali reza for russia
and we'll get uh alejandro also to weigh
in i think alejandro is also taking
taking alire as we've we've yeah we've
got some some inside scoop on alejandro
speak here oh okay
and shout out to to our good friend
alejandro who volunteered to be in the
truck
telling us telling us the you know
correcting our mistakes and providing us
with valuable info
and just generally keeping us on the
straight and narrow which is required
very much so
um by the way is it disappointing to you
i i feel disappointed when i see mvl
as saying the incredibly solid queens
gambit
uh
it i want to see that it used to be
heartbreaking it used to be
heartbreaking it kind of no longer is
because i've resigned myself to it i've
been watching it for about a year and
now yeah i've sort of resigned myself to
it i realize this is you know the the
part of the new normal you know
and
none of the new normal is any good
and honestly like very very little of
the new normal i'm i'm enjoying
currently and uh yeah mvl not playing
the greenfield definitely belongs in
that category but it's solid and he
seems to have good results with it and
uh
so do we have any more full-time
groomfeld players at your lead level
nowadays except you peter
uh yeah i'm i don't like there there's a
number of descriptors there which don't
apply to me so
i'm not i'm not counted in that
conversation but yeah zappos seems to
have kind of full time not so much
full-time maybe not so much yeah people
still can play the i mean the pretty
much every single person in the
tournament could potentially play it
once or twice like all of them know it
but it feels like fabiano was a
full-time grunfeld player growing up and
then he just gave it away mvl obviously
he just
resigned the groomfield like a year ago
who else is there in the mix
uh yeah i mean it's it's unclear like
occasional grimfield still still pops up
and i think there will be greenfields in
this tournament even but but yeah it
seems like people people are uh shifting
away uh from it and uh yeah it's it's
curious i think it's more to do with the
fashion than with you know anything
specifically wrong with the opening i
think the opening is
about as healthy as
uh as it has been over the years i don't
think much much has happened to uh how
it stands but yeah
qga
appears to be the order of the day for
from many many of these guys
speaking of the queen's gambit accepted
christian
i'm a little bit surprised to see this
night sitting on the d2 square actually
uh
is that a trend i think we've transposed
to to something that we've we've been uh
covering uh during the bucharest and
right so yeah i think the the early
akiba rubenstein b2b3 and then the
knight does but
somehow this very early development of
the knight to d2 is off you are very
much correct yes indeed i was looking uh
through the lines here and bishop to b3
is the main line d takes c5 another one
inviting uh the all-known end game
knight to d2 is all the way to only 36
games being played in this option with
knight to d2 knight to c3 for example
which is close to the 10th uh try in
this position has 298 games so knight
bd2 definitely a sideline and after uh
c64 knight takes d4 bishop to e7 only
one game was played in this position
with the move b3n essaying the type of
plan that we're actually seeing in the
game developing right now but he first
starts with this move bishop to e2 b3
and now b5 i would assume bishop to e2
to give white the option of potentially
meeting the move b5 with an immediate
bishop to f3 take control of the long
diagonal let's see what white is going
to come up in this position all right
well we're talking about the opening i
want to just say this is an end game
yeah we went from opening to end game in
the game between jeffrey and jan
like that um it's all reasonably well
known yeah and it's a it's a very
topical line which uh i think uh has
become a kind of a
go-to line to uh equalize without sort
of ever having any winning chances for
black kind of right you know the
approach uh
that against 1d4
various openings i think kind of vie for
for that
uh for for that like the the berlin
against one g4 this is maybe the berlin
against one g4 i see even though i feel
like it's maybe slightly unfair because
the berlin actually does result in black
winning some games right whereas this
feels to me that like black really is
trying to just equalize but they do they
do equalize very very often
i'm assuming we're capturing here peter
no we yeah he's playing he's playing g6
i'm a bit surprised by this i would have
taken and played king e7 i think quite
happily i understand our h-pawn is
a bit weak and we will be we would be a
bit worse there but
just how much wars is unclear to me but
then again you know you you will
rarely find me extremely unhappy with
the prospect of not giving up bishops
for nights so exactly if kg6 works there
is absolutely nothing wrong with it and
the fact that jeffrey pretty much
instantly plays a23 after king g6
suggests to me that you know even this
probably isn't new to to them exactly
kg2 a2 a3 appeared really quickly kind
of instantly yeah
and why is that a helpful tempo for
white you don't want to play moves like
i don't quite know or g3 i i can
understand why we're not playing g3
because exactly the plan that you were
showing of the bishop ez6 and then king
e7 i think we won the third rank for the
rook i see i think like i can i can
quite easily explain why g3 is not being
played
exactly why a3 is the most useful tempo
that we're spending here right now
or something i don't know that would be
that would be much harder for me to
to uh to grasp without you know having
ever looked at this position properly
and yet both of the players both players
are just
like yeah a2 a3 that's in my book that's
what i expected f7 f5 f6
f5 is very logical you want to like not
even having to think about bishop d3
check even though it didn't look very
threatening but right kind of making it
not not be a check is useful okay and we
have christian with a kind of a more
quirky opening in the opening i like i
like much more uh than this one in the
game between alireza and shah i think
absolutely yes that's the one that this
one is just simply crazy and there are
so many nuances that i want to point out
this position with the early move bishop
to e7 without the knight on f6 it
signals the fact that black wants to
play f5 without having the knight on f6
so the question is what is white going
to answer with and immediately attacking
the center with d4 seems to be the most
topical idea now black responded to the
move f5 and the main line in the
position is the move bishop to g2 knight
to f6 knight to f3
after bishop to g2 knight to f6 knight
to f3 and now the move e4 the problem is
that knight to h4 right now does not put
enough pressure
on the pawn on f5 and i can just simply
go knight to f5 attack the knight and
now you're in a pretty bad situation
with the white pieces so that's why
firuja decides to go with the move
bishop to h3 this is a very very
interesting one e takes d4 was the move
but bishop to knight to f6 in my opinion
was the natural way to approach the
position just continue your development
but the problem is after knight to f3 e4
is no longer a good move because i can
just simply go knight to h4 attacking
immediately the pawn on f5 if you do
play the move g6 this allows me to go
potentially bishop to h6 and not allow
black to castle a lot of nuances in this
position not only that but also with the
spawn h3 i can easily reroute this
knight via g2 knight to g2 knight to for
very intriguing so black decided to take
on d4 queen takes d4 knight to c6 and
now this is the position we see on the
board a lot of tension on this pawn on
f5 i really like what white is doing in
this game guys back to you
and after this move uh knight uh c6
queen d3 it is is
just briefly just briefly
to explain what we're showing to our
viewers there's a very marked contrast
between uh between the uh uh nippongi
game on the left there where there is a
lot of stuff traded off already right
both players are blitzing and on the
right there is the linear game against
hikaru a reasonably well known
theoretical italian in progress there
but with only one piece traded like
everything to play for so very very
different
uh
different approach to how uh how the
opening has panned out so far okay very
nice and uh just coming back to the
farouza game for a moment um
the move knight c6 attacking the queen
i'm always thinking that well i mean the
queen's ready to go back to d2
i mean if you made a if you made an
argument for any one of the three
squares d3 d2 d1 i could follow it yes
right yeah but of all of them d3 invited
knight e5 perhaps we should we should
explain to the viewers i mean g7 does
that doesn't look like it's hanging and
we haven't mentioned the fact that yeah
it seems like we're winning something
but in fact we're losing something here
and we are losing it straight away with
bishop f6 right yeah 23 does look
logical because i don't think we're very
worried about 95 i think it goes to c2
and yeah we do want to keep an eye on
that uh on that f5 f5 pawn i very much
understand why quinte 2 was chosen and i
also
kind of like the idea that shah has
chosen and reply he's played bishop f6
continuing sort of to ignore the fact
that this pawn is hanging and perhaps if
white takes on a fight here black will
just very happily take on c3 maybe even
like just go for positional compensation
something like takes stakes take on f5
and play i don't know queen f6 and just
claim that
you know this kind of brings back
memories of my childhood right it looks
like it's yeah it looks like a budapest
right honestly it looks like a fantastic
budapest okay to my eyes it feels that
black can really not be worse here at
all
and i i don't expect bishop takes a five
two uh to happen to be honest i think
knight g5 looks very large not only that
but you can even improve on the version
that you were just mentioning you take
on c3
you can include 95 as well yeah that's
that's a very good point yeah
and that's an amazing position yeah it
just looks very very nice the queen
trade
yeah i think bishop 5 is extremely
unlikely it's not a good move yeah i
think 95 is logical if not 95 i would
just go night of three i think we need
to start bringing stuff into play right
um
so that would be my two main choices
here
but i feel like black's
pieces are a little bit awkward like if
you put the bishop on g7 that makes a
lot of sense as opposed to being uh
attackable if you if you will the move
knight d5 looks to my eyes as a very
attractive move i certainly i'm
yeah i think if 95 happens i i'm
assuming it gets smoked out to me like
95 followed by c6 probably happens he
took on f5
well that is shocking to me i like i am
very very surprised by this it just
doesn't seem
[Music]
like this is a good decision right yeah
actually c3 seems like an automatic yeah
especially after you play bishop to f6
yeah yeah that plays itself so we take
take i really like including 95 here i
think winning the stamp cannot possibly
be a bad idea so queen goes anywhere c2
i guess we take on a five we go i still
like my queen i think the choice here is
between queen f6 and queen d7 and i
don't know which one is stronger but
we're choosing one of those two he's
going straight into that variation queen
f6 looks
very very attractive i mean
if we're going to trade queen yeah
let's get our knight going i think the
issue with queen of six specifically is
that there is queen e4 and we cannot
challenge that queen straight away so we
might have to castle long and then
rupivan might be a bit awkward so i
think maybe there is an argument for
queen g7
because if you if you after queen d7
queen e4 if we go back there if i play
queen g7 and we are just despite black
being upon down like all of these end
games white will be fighting for for
equality in them so if you play queen e4
here i think i can make an argument
tonight f6 yeah just going another
season castling short and saying
i'm playing from my 80. i'm playing for
mate now yeah now it's just terrible i
mean you've got one queen
and a weakness
like yes yes white is two pawns up but i
think black could be just winning
exactly it's very possible to imagine
this [ __ ] just being straight up
winning all of those wonderful czech
meeting patterns that we learned
with the smothered mate uh looks like
farrugia is actually seizing
uh an inferior position right out of the
i
am very very surprised by bishop takes a
five uh
truly
uh what else uh christian has crossed
your
uh well i was looking uh to see what's
happening in the dominguez versus
nakamura game as well it seems like
nakamura is uh both players in fact are
very very well prepared in this joko
piano type a setup and now we see d5 on
an interesting break in the center black
is putting pressure in the center as
much as possible nevertheless at the
same time there's this battle between
the ongoing uh avalanche of pawns on the
queen side that white is employing
potentially signaling that at some point
maybe i will go c5 and just lock the
bishop on a7 that's an option as well
also potentially opening up the c file
and uh putting up the business on the c
file bishop to c3 this is the position
we currently have nakamura still
struggling right now to find the exact
plan but definitely very very intriguing
game in uh this one much more of a
strategical approach compared to the one
between firuja and mamedyarov peter i
got to ask you the question i we just
saw this move d65
by hikaru and the first thought that
comes to my mind why can't we just win
the pawn on e5 i'm not entirely sure
thank you thank you exactly first of all
why can't i take this pawn i i know that
there's oftentimes a bishop f2 but it
doesn't feel like it's working here
right
yeah it's it's a bit confusing because
none of the immediate solutions are
solutions
as far as i can tell like dc4 dc4
doesn't really improve anything as far
as i can tell also knight takes gcc
exists but that's the right story right
right queen b6 i thought maybe queen b6
but uh
yeah here i think maybe it works which
is why i was mentioning 9996 right but
if you do it without trading on c4 like
if you play qb6 here and i will play
queen g2 and now c4 c5 is a very strong
threat so uh yeah shutting down
i'm a bit i'm a bit confused as to at
least why this wasn't uh you know
considered for longer but
uh linear is playing in particular by
his standards i think linear is playing
very quickly so so maybe he just sort of
knows what he's doing and
despite all of this looking very very
non-forced linear is one of the leading
theoreticians of these particular
positions in the djoko piano and
i wouldn't be shocked if he actually uh
had this looked at
um
christian just clear our cobwebs if you
don't mind
seven knight takes e5 uh how did the
computer
uh queen c7 yeah in this position maybe
queen c7 actually yeah
ggg3 yeah
there's a g3 tempo so remind me again
the yeah exactly sorry it was the game
between lanier and ikaro we just saw
this move d5 so after bishop to c3
instead of no instead of c3
yeah right yeah yeah
yeah
and there's a lot of compensation also
you have to watch that's what we uh you
cannot take on g6 because after queen to
g3 unfortunately you're in deep trouble
yeah knight on g6 i'm pre the pawn on f2
is on pre as well and of course you
cannot take the queen on g very nice
move queen to c7 and i'm sure hikaru saw
that
uh
sorry apologies just continue your
position in 97 check
after the movement i think you're just
getting yes
i mean rookie seven can have two queen
bits
thank you thank you thank you for
finally
so
maybe i was trying to justify the move
bishop c3
maybe we just discovered because we're
going to the same line and then the
bishop is on c3 there's no more queen to
b2 and right it could be it could be
that potentially okay and finally peter
uh now that we've cleared the cobwebs as
far as taking on e5 there's still one
game
takes takes in c5 i think this is very
strategically double-edged because the
bishop will come out by b8 eventually
and also even the 45 sorry d5 d4
followed by 95 could be quite awkward
actually i saw with some pressure
against our queen side here always
trying to kill the bishop the bishop is
not going to be all that all that dead
yeah it comes back into the game by the
b8 square eventually wonderful and you
were about to say we've got one game
remaining yeah we haven't looked at yeah
we haven't looked at fabi's game against
sam shankland at all which is another
one of those really really slow uh
joko pianos a slightly different
structure to the one in the game between
linear and uh hikaru because i think it
could have been exactly the same but
uh
sam on move nine
just briefly to show our viewers how we
got here it basically it it went very
much along the same route and then after
rookie one uh uh sam when b6 without
without preparing it
without any of the preparation
and uh and this is another structure
which is
uh very topical very kind of hotly
discussed these days
right uh with black
you know you can you can make an
argument that black has compromised
their structure in the center a little
bit but it's difficult to attack
obviously and
opening i mean semi-opening the air file
does give black the option of as sm has
done doubling on the air file and trying
to hoping to create some pressure
against the white kings i remember a
very impressive game from bucharest it
was between duda and fabiano where that
where duda somehow managed to keep his
king side all intact and he rebuffed all
of fabi's attempts to get at him and won
a nice game uh
[Music]
it that was from the candidates right
was it the candidate i think it was the
candidate
i i went bucharest for some reason that
was on my mind
you know it's strange before the advent
of computers you would look at a
position like this and you would say oh
black is marvelously coordinated
there's a queen on h4 there's a knight
on g6 the doubled rooks the bishop on a7
and yet the computers could sit there
and say that white is probably slightly
better a bit better yep generally i
think the engines are not that impressed
with these types of structures and do
prefer white
uh it's a bit curious because yeah i i
started off like i underwent the more or
less a you know 180
180 uh transfer transformation because i
think when i was when i was a kid i
would just take any of these positions
with black very very happily enough
exactly i would think this is fantastic
and these days in these days both in the
italians and also in the
you know the the int marshalls and in
the slow royal opuses
as black i very much prefer not to
double my my pulmonary yeah like i just
don't like the structure anymore at all
having sort of looked at it seriously
with modern engines and also having
watched strong players play it from the
white side it just
at some point you realize it's really
not that much fun
just defending these double pawns and
christian jump right in uh i was looking
at this position actually and i was
trying to uh see what the better
opportunities black had in the position
and actually he could have uh went this
route tried to go for the c4 square this
is a big weakness in white's camp so
after taking on d4c take d4 knight to b6
this is not an easy move to make of
course after queen to b3 it's very easy
to see that d5 is going to strengthen uh
this control over the c4 square this
knight is going to jump to the outpost
on c4 and that's going to give black a
tremendously good position now the
problem is after knight to b6 it's very
easy to look at this situation and
expect to move a d5 setting up this pin
on the a7 g1 diagonal but black can
still play the move knight to c 4 bishop
to a7 knight takes b2 queen to c2 or
queen to b3 and you might be thinking
okay the knight on b2 is lost i cannot
defend it if i do play the move queen to
f6 after the move e5 i'm going to be
busted in the position so you i cannot
do that but what i can do is actually
just simply play the move b6 this bishop
on a7 is going to be lost in next few
moves not only that but you also have to
deal with a weakness on f2 this would
actually have given black quite a
tremendous advantage and if you do allow
me to get my knight to c4 that's going
to allow me to get a better strategical
position big big opportunity missed by
sam shanklin
and interestingly i think maybe this is
why uh uh fabi
very uh quickly uh once this did not
happen or five spend the tempo on a4a5
actually cutting away the b6 square from
the d7 knight and we are going to have a
similar structure on the board right now
with some actually going for the cd4 cd4
d5 break but with the pawn on a5
getting any of his knights to c4 is
going to be a possibility challenge
yeah because currently all of the
squares which you know feed into the c4
square will be taken away i assume white
plays e5 exactly exactly
as well yeah just just take i mean
black's position will be incredibly
solid i think what sam is banking on
here is that if fight goes e5
he will not really have much in the way
of counter play
but
with white not really having any breaks
available to uh to them on the queen
side will have to try to win the game on
the king side where i think it's
reasonably easy to mount a very solid
defense using like ff5 as a
as a blog post and so on but
yeah it's so
as as christian uh pointed out doing
all of these things when 9694 was still
on the table right was was a lot more
attractive because now that knives b7 is
very very hamstrung yeah makes a massive
difference
teleporting the knight from d7 to c4 and
where it's very active to uh still being
on a passive square it does feel like
white's uh certainly for choice here
christian any of the players making any
progress in any of the other games i
have these pages the games are pretty
slow right now slowly developing i might
add but this one right now furuja is be
thinking for the last seven minutes
after queen to d7 realizing that he's
just simply much worse in the position
knight to f3 is going to be very
difficult uh to be played now with a
potential queen to h3 and keep the king
in the center not allow it to castle
this is looking very dangerous for white
if you do take on d7 we know that this
end game is just simply going to be
superior for the black pieces there's
absolutely no strategical reasons in the
position uh for which white should be
better he doesn't want to see this on
the board he is right now regretting the
fact that he took so easily and so
quickly on f5 the other ones are pretty
much developing at a very slow pace we
know jeffrey versus nepo is this end
game which probably is not going to go
anywhere it does seem like nepo just
equalized out of this opening once again
showcasing how good he is in the opening
phase after the world championship match
and aronian versus mvl this one is this
is one is the interesting one right
exactly yes yes there's an extra pawn
but this beautiful bishop on b7 now we
see this rook to d5 potentially eyeing
the square g5 and putting even more
pressure on the pawn on g2 this one is
going to get spicy in the next few moves
exactly now peter on this game between
levon and uh mvl
um
this is tough for our audience because
you know we were raised the knight is
worth three the bishops were three now
this is just a clean extra pawn on b3
now maybe that pawn on b3 isn't
bothering anybody for the moment but a
lot of players in our audience would be
sitting there saying come on why isn't
this just good for
white why is the two bishops
i think it's compensation
it's not just the bishop there it's the
fact that the bishop on b7 is unopposed
and uh white is not very well equipped
to deal with potential threats against
uh against the king side both g5 and
actually rook h5 i think is maybe a more
annoying threat in something
a little bit on h2 as well the one
question i have right now is
you have to calculate bishop a5 and so
far like i'm not entirely sure what's
happening there i guess he just wants to
play queen b8 and if we go knight b6
seemingly winning some more material we
will have a tempo both rogue g5 and rook
h5 will actually save uh save the
exchange the rooks yeah because
obviously you cannot take on c8 and give
up give up your yeah you just get mated
into there
exactly
exactly
so he played queen to e2 he played queen
e2 and then uh
yeah i would start with rook h5
i think
i don't particularly want to provoke f2
f3 i think f2f3 is a move that white
would very much like to make anyway so
yeah like rook g5 f3 seems to me like
we've we've improved wise a little bit
so
yeah i'm not a huge fan of that but i am
a fan of the idea of playing rook h5
first and then i mean g3 is ugly and if
you play h3
here already i can maybe consider going
rook g5 and if you play f3 i will have
at least knight h59 g3
having provoked h2h3 uh we definitely
get more squares
and more squares to try and create some
kind of initiative on the king's side
created the point there's also you you
can just play position as well you can
probably once again kind of depending on
whether we're blundering inside of h5
bishop by 596 still remains something
but like just playing 94 and playing
positionally here is not it's not really
uh oh
there you have a very nice example of
lavon's
fashion yeah sartorial sartorial icon of
the chess world for sure exactly we're
waiting for him to have his own uh line
of clothes
before too long uh
very very colorful uh we love you lavon
knight e4 also uh
looks like just a nice and mvl goes for
for a move we did not consider but
which kind of it's a nod towards the
bishop five knight b6 ideas i think now
we know
uh well also attacking the other knight
on d4 asking the question of whether you
know whether you want to play knight f3
or whether you want to
do something else if you don't mind me
that does beg the question of
this uh i mean if you're going to put
the queen on e2 and if you put
you know you kind of think that maybe
the bishop 65 is a thread though yeah
yeah exactly you you sit there and say
well i i i should just start with
queenie two more let's look at the
knight before maybe it gets then i have
to do then i have to do this one i don't
know bishop two probably he just didn't
very much
didn't
like all that much
and you have to
um i mean knight c5 here might already
be quite like you you might have to
problematic resign yourself to defending
some slightly awkward end games yeah
like it looks like i might be just
winning the pawn on b3 next movements at
least in some cases right so yeah i can
understand why bishop happened
but we do in the game we do have the
position after bishop c5 excuse me yeah
and i'm wondering if
i'm wondering if after bishop c5
i think to me that option would be quite
attractive i would like to calculate
bishop a5 i suspect it's a bailout but
if it actually gives me a solid
a solid bailout and then now after
knight b6 anyway
are you still we still have rook g500 h5
right nothing changed right i thought
maybe something changed with the
inclusion of
uh with the inclusion of queen e2 bishop
c5 but i still don't see it because i
would like to trade something like yeah
despite being a healthy pawn up
let's go back to that position after h5
um can i continue with f4 maybe ah
yeah that's a that's maybe a good move
yeah
my idea is that if you do go to e8 i
have this idea of knight d7 ah this is
clever yeah this is now that the rook is
on h5 using yeah using the fact that
rook on h5 is kind of vulnerable yeah
this is clever
and if you do go to d8 maybe i can just
retreat knight to c4 and go to go to e5
it feels like that rook on h5 is a bit
mm-hmm
yeah absolutely and
he goes knight a5 which is a move we did
not consider but
knight a5 yeah knight a5 protecting the
knight on d4 attacking the bishop on b7
kind of a logical move if you think
about it we're obviously misplacing that
piece a little bit but
aren't we doing the same for ourselves
though
that's the one i'm in
i'm not the bishop
not the bishop no no no no no no no no
no no no no i'm in the knight
i guess his plan is just to play roxy
one here and claim uh
right i have some speed right now mm-hmm
queen to d7 maybe
rook ac4 and you know ah
now things are coordinating at last
claim claim that you know i've i've
improved at least some things in my
position well
i'm creating some ideas this is looking
good for white okay the double rooks at
least uh
anything uh
i was thinking that maybe we could also
if we include the move rook h5 h3 we
could maybe uh
i don't know put the bishop on a little
maybe slightly yeah
h5 does make uh some sense
it's interesting that you know my biases
are
so i really want to pronounce here
because
in my mind i'm fighting for equality
here with white
which i think is just completely
completely unreasonable and white
probably is under under no threat
whatsoever if you ask the machine i
suspect but right
let's ask the machine in this case
christian what does the machine tell us
about yes
just fine plus 0.3 okay not a
significant advantage black definitely
has enough compensation uh but white is
still uh on top so what was the move
that you guys recommending a bishop to
a8 already problematic after rook to c4
is even stronger
rook to c1 this is good as well
nevertheless the same idea
c1 rook to c4 double up on the c file
that's going to create some serious
tension on the b spawn c5 so you cannot
afford to lose that tempe rook to h5 was
the other move that you guys were
mentioning after h3 does seem like white
is actually building up a significant
advantage this rook on h5 is actually
not that well placed if you do go bishop
to a8 right now once again rook to c4
this is the big problem and i think
mvl's decision is also a very good
indication of where he thinks he played
94 he just said okay the bishop
is important but
i need to
i need to play concretely and it's an
admission that white is doing fine
because obviously if you if you have to
part with your bishop player exactly
you're really no longer playing for a
win you're just playing to equalize but
probably you do equalize though
great move
okay the
knight to oh sorry this is the wrong
position this is knight a5
knight e4
um
intriguing it is it is very intriguing
here yeah i
the issue is that with a knight on e4 if
we take on b7 black will just be
threatening to take on d4 and win the
pawn on b3 in every single position so
you know
[Music]
your situation is a bit awkward so i'm
wondering if we can still play maybe
roxy roxy rook c4 rook c1 c4 bishop a6
oh yeah this is the point yeah this is
why we kept the bishop on b7 i guess can
we play rook c1 in the current position
without trading on b7 let's see
ruxin
i mean i assume it's playable but
i don't know if it's any good 92 and e65
is kind of worrying me a little bit i
want to say i just blundered it maybe b3
before will bail me out
but i
right i think it i think it actually
probably does uh bail you out before she
thinks before actually is i mean we
don't need to we don't need to go
too far into the into the weeds and in
fact rook to c1 is according to the
engine at least the best movie in the
place whoa okay that's that's actually
quite surprising because it
it started looking to me like it's just
a blunder
just to clear my cobwebs once more uh
knight takes b7 queen takes b7 knight f3
give me the knight on e4 if you take on
d2 which you know
yeah this is i assume i'm largely better
yeah
maybe not even that marginally because
attacking the pawn on b3 is not it's not
fair i'm assuming we're not taking on g2
you are actually yeah we are you do take
on d2 and what rook to d8 not not right
now not rook to d no rook takes c2 look
to d8 right now rook to d8 immediately
you take on d2 you do take on d2 first
okay and then
rook cd8 i assume it looks cd8 yes and i
guess i do something ah you mean queen
claiming that you have enough confidence
queen before yeah
that's annoying sorry sorry i i have
missed queen before when i went into
this whole line
okay so uh
looks like a draw
well rook to c1 still puts a lot of
pressure okay sorry black is not as easy
to simplify the position if you do go
for it that line that peter recommended
knight takes d2 and e5 it does seem that
after knight takes b7 it's actually
white who is starting to build up a
significant advantage
uh ruptured
exactly and this is the key move after
e5 take on b7 queen takes b7
the key move is queen to c2
oh good grief disgusting queen to c to
it if you take on d4 i just simply take
back on d4 and then i'm going to
recapture brook to c4 is also coming if
i have to reinforce uh that control over
the c file
i'm just simply going to be a pawn up
queen c2 just disgusting really
disgusting
breaking the pen peter
my new book breaking
that's basic stuff guys basic stuff
thank you very much for the basics
winning by anthony he played bishop e1
by the way bishop e1 oh my goodness
lavonne from the mind of levon
that's one of those moves that my coach
would tell me ugly moves are not good
moves but
the more you look at it you start
understanding that f3 followed by bishop
to g3 is coming so it's not as ugly as
it first uh looks firsthand
it looks ugly let me just boldly state
that it doesn't agree yeah it doesn't
look great wow okay
um let's let's just go around the horn a
little bit more here and by the way are
we inviting our audience yes we are we
always uh like your feedback tell us
what we're doing right what you like and
we're ready to answer all questions what
do you think people all questions is a
very bold statement but really the
answer some questions
well one after the other one
some some questions for sure so uh by
all means do uh let us know uh what uh
you would like to ask
of our staff here um fabi let's just
jump to fabi's game uh yeah it's the one
with sam shanklin
it's a weird one because yeah i've i've
been trying to figure out if i actually
like the counter play that sam has on
the king side enough to maybe adjust my
assessment but maybe it's just not going
anywhere because he's he's sort of fully
extended now he's got g5 king six and h5
all of those moves in
g5 g4 but g5 g4 doesn't really do very
much the knight is two moves away from
landing on c5 and he does go g4
it's very logical
hang on a second he wants to play rook
f2 right
what so if we take twice at some point
if we take twice he wants to maybe take
on e5
and then go
either the immediate rook of two or take
on e3 and rook of two maybe d5 d4 first
is also a move d5 d4 is actually pretty
good instead of all this because here
you ah d5
d5 this one actually captures the it
captures the bishop and there is an even
better move
except knight to e5 rook to f4
whoa that is very say what
look for here rooker iv kind of ends the
game yeah
before we win the full rook with bishop
d4 we should fabi's in trouble right now
guys wow g4 yeah he
was too flippant about this g5 g4 he
didn't
fully uh
i mean he was moving his knight around
right i mean his night his knight came
from g4
so he spent like one
two
three moves and by that time sam said
let me pry open the king side this is
impressive christian and by the way the
way to get out of this mess or at least
try to uh get out is not human-like
because check this out after g4 take on
g4 take on g4 f4 is the best move in the
position just simply giving up a pawn
after rook takes f4
knight to b3 defending the pawn on d4
and without a white pawn on g4 the rook
cannot go to g4 so it's worse to take on
g4 and be a pawn up than to just simply
give up a pawn for free with f4 a human
will never make this move f well i can
get i think i think you can i think you
can get there simply by process of
eliminating as usual everything else
loses yes yes
i think this is how people generally uh
and something really weird happened in
the uh levons okay oh whoa
what in lavon's game as well well
because for a second there i thought
okay there's a knight
on previous on on e4 but
queen takes e4 rook g5 i guess
that's so clear maybe even rook h5 uh
rook h5 maybe is a little bit more
on point yeah yeah yeah yeah g5 also
doesn't doesn't look half bad if i if i
have to
you have to say yeah okay yeah no the e4
knight is definitely not hanging back to
pardon me to the game of fabby because i
didn't think we really
fully uh
went through those lines that you were
about to show as christians so you were
saying
yeah which is good yeah we need to keep
the king's side as closed as possible to
have time to play 93 knight c5 and seal
off but this is also psychologically so
difficult it is difficult but you're
just a pawn down right now if everything
else loses you might still play this you
might have to yeah because you just
realize that everything else is just so
much worse but yeah none of this is easy
of course it's it's not a comfortable
decision the problem is you see f takes
g4 and you might also spot the move
knight takes c5 which is problematic as
well right so perhaps for that reason
you will be drawn to the move f4 in the
end but yeah but just playing a phone
knowing that it will it will get
captured and you can't you can't
it's difficult yeah it's it's it's a
difficult choice yeah my my question is
uh an ib3 here yeah uh just trying to
stabilize trying to put the knight on c5
and then we we play
yeah a position where the extra pawn is
on b7 which isn't the greatest extra
fighter
it really isn't the most impressive
extra pawn in the world but maybe
but the hg hg f4
knight b3
uh if he finds it it's a great bale it
is a very very difficult sequence but he
might i mean this is fabian exactly he's
very very good
at understanding what needs to be done
yeah and and doing it despite it you
know maybe looking just very very
unattractive this is a position that
shanklin's coach would probably include
in uh some of his books aguard this type
of g4 you take on g4 and then you play
f4 and somehow you equalize the position
uh very important i want to i want to
start
like
it's still fine yeah i've i was going to
say uh
is level after all much better in his
game against mvl but yeah rook c4 is a
clever move because now the
the queen is i assume has to go
somewhere let's say b8 and we can take
on c8 and take on e4 and now rook h5
attacks nothing right but rg5 still
works right rook g5 distilled weirdly
rook g5 still works we don't need to
like those two pieces are enough
this is our counter play and you can't
really take it away
interesting truly
so he's choosing a square he can
provided he has rook g5 at the end he
can choose pretty much any square and
you know
you can make him make an argument for
queen d7 exactly
uh just to sidestep any potential uh
pitfalls of placing that queen on the
dark square because right we own the the
light squares as black in this position
i assume once again uh that uh having
placed the bishop on e1 you're gonna go
f3 to f3 window of three somewhere yeah
and make sure that we we get out uh
sorry i wanted to go to uh the game of
geoffrey
zhang for a moment because once again
that it was a game that you know just
went from opening to end game yeah very
very quickly and
yeah
young has a couple of opportunities
already just to make an immediate draw
but he's continuing to play on uh hoping
perhaps that his outside passer
might give him a winning chance
somewhere along the way but it doesn't
really feel like that because it's very
very well blocked on before we play i
mean 94 is probably very comfortable
draw bishop c4 followed by knight g4
should be a very comfortable draw right
yeah i don't think uh i don't think uh
anybody is really winning this position
94 knight c3 on the board as you can see
is anybody trying
bishop
jan clearly is trying because i think
he's already uh
refused a couple of opportunities to
trade knights and just guys i think
shake hands so say something like simply
yeah simply by the process of you know
deduction or going yeah you don't go for
visuals of apples guys yes yes can we go
through the neck meraki absolutely uh
i'm 100 sure what i'm saying but after
knight to e7 can i just pick up the e5
pawn yeah i think he wants to take maybe
play queen d5 or something but yeah i'm
not i'm not sure if he thinks that's
enough compensation no i mean just give
up the central pawn like that i think
you probably kind of
maybe you don't get it because if eight
i think is the plan i would assume so i
think i think it's an indication that he
really just liked his position i think
this is what happened there 97 i mean
it's clearly not a blunder you can't
really blunder a central pawn like this
uh
you know if you're if you're a hikaru
we're pretty sure he knows he he left it
on trees
so i think it's a very clear indication
it's a very clear indication that he was
not enjoying how the game was going and
he felt that
you know i think c5 is not yet on the
board no you have other options you can
maybe start with bishop three you can
bishop a3
yeah i mean the knight on c5 is clearly
the best piece agreed like black has
absolutely so trading it off is i think
it's just generally very much in white's
favor but in order to do that you have
to you know
the board foreign but after all it is it
is a very healthy central pawn so why
wouldn't we so perhaps this is uh what
he missed after queen to d5
it does seem like rook to e8 is actually
a pretty significant threat because the
following d3 is kind of feeble sensible
in the position bishop to a3 ah even
here
this might actually be a big problem
and we have queen eight in the end or
something yeah rookie eight
perhaps i can just simply take on c5
yeah but then rook takes e5 or maybe i
will make a draw like make a draw like
that yeah i mean it's it's going to be a
very very miserable draw but maybe i do
make it yeah i'm not going to enjoy a
single moment of it though like take
only five take on a faithfully queen of
three
it's just so miserable actually
yeah i wouldn't recommend it uh yeah i
don't know why i'm why i'm suggesting
this is playable
no it might not be lost already but it's
definitely you know white difference in
the vicinity
and the vicinity well let's see they're
going straight into that line knight
except five e takes f5 is on the board
okay it's on the board what else is but
if you don't play queen d5 like the
previous play just makes no sense
whatsoever he's going for it
yeah he might be
he might have missed bishop to a3
simple as that
and in fact the engine is saying that
after queen to d5 if you don't play the
move bishop to a3 blackjack simply
equalized ah okay so it's it's you know
this much of a difference bishop to a3
is plus three
what bishop to a3 is completely over
by the way according to the enemy
according to the according to the end
according to the engine of course not
for humans for humans
nice judgment on that ending
[Laughter]
plus three is objectively right now
hikaru is dead lost wow
that's so
wow that's and by the way fabiano seems
to be on a nine minute thing after the
move g4 f takes g4 he took fghg and now
yeah no no he he took with the f pawn
yeah exactly yeah that's a problem fg
fghg and now he has he no longer has the
the blockading uh idea of f4 f4 f4 and
gh is just such a massive uh positional
threat down to his last two minutes guys
this is not good news no not at all
well whoa whoa whoa that
that would be quite uh
a blow uh to his sales uh losing with
white with the white ones
yeah
continuing uh
yeah this is a topic we will have two
weeks of potentially talking about this
but uh you guys are sort of closer and
you know the club the club is
uh you know famous for you know having
uh having uh fabi you know close to its
heart right absolutely
like do you have any
lukewarm takes on the subject of his
form like what's happening
yeah uh
it's kind of
depressing actually to kind of watch him
kind of sing sing from clearly the
number two player in the world from the
2018 world championship match to
you know struggling to well just stay in
the top ten and it's uh
yeah it's very um
disheartening yeah it's
adjectives and yeah covering the the
olympiad in chennai was just
at times hard to watch him uh you know
struggle with himself
more than anything else i think he is
just kind of
uh
struggling to uh
you know recapture some of the
confidence that he's had over the years
but yeah that's actually
exactly clearly clearly not himself and
the the the question that you know
people uh people are sort of trying to
figure out is sort of what is causing us
yeah liking it's not the the what we're
watching we kind of know what we're
watching right now we're just trying to
figure out why we're watching it
uh
and yeah there are there are some ideas
on on that topic but yeah one he was he
was number two in the world for so many
years he was established as the second
best player after magnus carlsen and it
felt like maybe there was a sense of
complacency in his play the problem is
once you go that route you only need a
couple of bad results and then you
immediately your confidence is going to
get shattered and we've seen that other
candidates immediately following it up
with the olympia which was just simply
horrendous yeah yeah
the the thing with with that statement
is like complacency is just not the word
i associate with anything
uh you know with anything to do with
here with the
uh fabulous chess i think you know
he's
generally is one of the less the least
complacent players in uh in in the game
uh but yeah it's it's just hard to you
know without
being a fabian sort of knowing what's
happening inside it's just so difficult
to judge but you know he's clearly
nowhere near
his
general level of play it's just
very very obvious well you know you're
well yourself peter i mean you've gone
through the ebbs and flows the ups and
downs and
you've been
you know there there were times in your
career when you just felt like
everything's going your way and there's
other times you're just saying you're
shaking your head wondering what's wrong
yeah you never exactly know yeah i mean
the the the one
guess that people have like the the
obvious surface explanation that people
have offered but once again without
the the knowledge of how things are
really are inside his mind it's
impossible to judge would be that
perhaps
he really did not believe at all
the idea that magnus might not play
and it all stems from the second half of
the candidates where he felt that you
know playing for second gives him
nothing right so he must absolutely must
go absolutely all in the second half
because only the first place matters
exactly uh and you have to assume that
the way he played in the first half if
he wanted to coast and and get the
second he would have gotten the second
he
achieved that
easily easily good enough to uh
to to to coast and control you know
control the controllables and
uh i mean nothing is ever guaranteed but
you would have
you would have assumed a young 30 years
old by the way i mean again he's still
in his prime um
universal rating system of 27 87
again a top top player but just
having difficulties yes absolutely and
not not playing anywhere near his
anywhere near his best we we we do have
uh two moves on the board rook h8 and by
the way
after the move rook i i was about to ask
you how what would be your approach here
as black uh when rook h8 came and
immediately it was almost like fabi
expected that movie [ __ ] is a logical
movie rook b3 we're just playing h1 so
we're sort of we're sort of inviting
rook h8 or rook h7 exactly with the
yeah it's still a horrible position to
look at but maybe rugby 3 is a clever
idea and once again fabi is
one of the most tenacious defenders in
world chess right now so he is doing the
right thing he's preparing for let's say
knight to five here because if if black
goes knight f5 we can take take we can
for instance play bishop g1 to g7 was
played bishop g1 and control the the h3
h3
yeah king g7 is a weird one i don't
quite know what that king g7 maybe he is
maybe he is opening up the g6 square to
play knight g6 instead of knight five
not to allow white any
d3
trades
on the board yeah rook g3 knight g6 and
then we have to make some very
uncomfortable choices once again we
might have to play king h2 why why did
we need rook t3 to defend the pawn on d4
just to sort of uh kind of also
knight i think we're still dreaming of
might be three nights okay
i can go with that dream i can get
behind that dream if we can
shut out that bishop that would be a
dream come true absolutely absolutely so
and pardon me you wanted to suggest
knight g6 i think maybe we actually
do we just give it up no it looks
horrible because king h2 doesn't like
king h2 provokes so many things like
ghgh95 or the immediate 95 on knight f4
here looks very strong as well like all
of these things look frightening wait
but why is this a problem i take on e5
yeah that may be [ __ ] play seven maybe
even bishop d4 yeah moves exist yeah for
sure
what happens there 95 we can take on a
seven second a7 bishop to d4 yeah and
take on e6 maybe even be greedy yeah oh
yeah i like that like knight g3 or b6
because that's greedy there are no there
are no immediate threats and we want to
bring the bishop back to uh to g4 and
we're controlling the f the square maybe
you can play c5 and claim that you have
rook to f2 coming in that position
but yeah we're guessing we're getting
way too uh way too far
okay so sorry just uh so rook teeth uh
king g7
vacating the the square g6 but i i kind
of liked your idea of using the f5
square actually i
didn't that i think
i think that that makes life slightly
easier actually if we if we get the
trade on if we get to trade on a five we
play bishop g1 and i would assume we
cover most things and we're by that
point really one move away from
completely stabilizing with knight b3
the best move in the position according
to the engines is actually a very funny
one king to g8
get out
king g7 rook d3 king g8 so that you
played the move rook to g7 later on yeah
this is this is not happening yeah let's
see let's see
by the way i am being told that
jeffrey's game not surprisingly uh yeah
is heading toward a quick draw as we've
got
you know that that one is not not long
for this world
g4 it takes king of five and by the way
guys everything is strategically done
done done like it's
yeah this is so yeah hikaru has
he can't manage to uh that's so
next round he got his pawn back yeah he
got his phone back but the e file is
gone and uh well
the light squares versus the dark
squares and it's not much of a contest
the light squares are winning this one
this knight on c4 is marvelous whereas
this bishop is just simply a big and
they're also tactical issues because
yeah like you would like to play king of
seven to at least control some squares
because i think rookie six currently is
the biggest threat white has but if you
play he played queen f5 he clearly
didn't like any of those other options
but yeah he is uh
so what if i just simply go rook to e6
now rookie six i guess you have to play
rook b8 and you ask i mean defend like
this passing yeah yeah
i mean i i'm not i'm not suggesting this
i'm just making making move by move here
right
and the first result of her tournament
is a draw as
the game never really got off
in fact this is what uh what jan did so
well in the candidates was neutralizing
everybody with black
and when they got frisky he won yes by
the way guys ferruja is also starting to
put some pressure on mommy and the arrow
in that end game he completely outplayed
we thought that uh ferrugia was actually
in trouble exactly he outplayed him in
the end game
uh this was where the queen went to d7
we left it
around these parts
and this is this is always the danger
that uh
you know if you allow y to to assume
this much control in the center f3 and
d4 is a very very useful
uh
kind of a barrier against yeah
yeah
suddenly it's very enjoyable because
black hasn't really achieved much uh on
the queen side just yet and this recon
g6 is massive it's uh
providing us with a lot of potential uh
threats and maybe even a 45 is a threat
right now like i i don't particularly
like moving them away from the light
squares because it will limit my own
bishop
but on the other hand you know pushing
them towards queenie
cannot be such a horrible idea push your
baby by the way no that rook on g6 is
doing a great job as you say i mean
controlling the six ring hitting the
pawn on g7 and rook h6 is uh i think an
indication of what shark thinks about
his position also it's a very cute
little tactical idea because r7 knight
five i guess is what the point is yeah
exactly and g3 is hanging does this work
knight h3 i was just
to say is
three or nine of seven yeah he's got
knight h3 yeah rook h
and knight h3 yeah using the fact that
the rook on h6 is hanging
young can you please move your
head away from the
uh there is a knight c3 check here
yes i um but we think with the bishop
and you said this perspective
yeah two pieces versus the uh just the
rook um
now having no knight takes g7 bishop h6
knight c3
not doable
no this is a this is a key moment right
40 seconds for mamedyaro 50 seconds for
furuja right now
with because i've i've taken a look at
the rest of the boards and i think this
is the one that we want to watch bobby's
position just quickly what did you think
if everything stabilized quite oh quite
significantly yeah
and hikaru is just suffering
yeah hikaru's position is not going to
change dramatically anytime soon he is
going to be worse but not lost like this
this kind of an equilibrium now he can
actually be quite significantly worse if
not completely lost on the screen
g5 there's
[Music]
but this one this one is sharper and
more fun so let's maybe stick with this
one well we clipped farouza is super
happy just clipped a very nice pond his
knight is about to land on the f4 square
and i've played b5 before which is a
very clever idea because 1905 is very
precariously placed and he's trying to
win the g4 square for it but what if i
just go rook to c1 now
yeah doesn't that defend everything
somehow i think i think the plan here oh
you just you can just take on c3 in the
end yeah exactly um this is that defense
f3 but you you you can still give me a
check yeah if you like two you take on
e4 right mm-hmm but then i take off but
let's see yeah i think this probably is
very strong knight c3 rook c3 94 check
we just go king of two
right and we're giving up the e4 okay
before we take on c5 with something i'm
guessing the g rook probably
yeah
we can also throw in either four yeah i
don't know if it would be either
oh this might even be stronger without
the seconds yeah this is looking great
for white but this looks like farouza
all the way rook c1 on the board five
seconds for chocolatier he has to make a
move three
make him move he goes
but this gives away time to play for
instance knight f4 or or king of two
just driving the knight away from i love
knight f4 bringing that knight back into
i think if tonight is awkward just
playing either four yeah although having
said that like actually there's so much
value in driving them by the way from a
five that
yeah he goes like the four doesn't have
a four but now you take take and then
there's knight g3 at the end yeah but
we're still winning that rook ending i
think very very comfortably so we don't
even have to worry bishop c3 knight g3
played can i play king e3 yeah king e3
might be winning but i think even if we
if even if we just take on g3 and go i
don't know rogue six check or something
i think we're just winning and then
bishop one ah king e395 is a problem
just go bish p1 and that knight only if
a4 is completely yeah just take you
mentioned yeah you need four funds you
probably throw yeah i think if you do
this the bishop will be stronger than
the knight but the rook ending was also
very very poor
even the immediate bishop one is quite
strong now still five seconds for ali
reza right now
yeah just got bishop one but yeah i live
five seconds is plenty foreign
you know the child of the modern age he
he knows yeah rook of six rug g5 he just
started collecting
this position just falls apart yeah rook
fade is a clever clever little idea
there by shock because f3 is really the
only legitimate target you can play
against and it was probably actually
missed by
i think he missed it yeah
and there is no sort of immediate
comfortable way of dealing with it yeah
very very awkward very nicely done by
loresa because we keep on talking about
this you know accepting your mistakes
and just saying yeah
this is my best move i'm going to make
it despite it looking like an admission
of guilt so to speak it's so it's a very
good skill it's a
realizing you've made a mistake owning
it and just playing objectively is is
not easy but good yeah i've always found
that to be to be one of the most
difficult things after spending a long
time over a decision ali reza keeps
collecting discovering it was a weak
decision and then
you know owning it as you say yeah uh
bishop takes a5
he's not trying away
he's joining the bankruptcy
i think i think yukara will get away
with it by the way there's no no
really
getting away with it i just have to
flash and take a quick look at that one
because he he looked like he was being
dominated yeah specifically move 37
there was a killing blow there after
rookie six king f7 uh
which uh right here instead of that
i don't see
rook takes b6 i assumed he's just
winning here i'm over yeah rugby six or
eight i guess rookie he got worried
about rookie it would be seven king f8
or something but there's really not
third yeah i can see why you would feel
slightly awkward about this right like
just a bit awkward but the problem is
that you get your queen to f3 quite
quickly yeah
yeah and queen d5 roxy seven it wasn't
what he did yeah but but yeah we're
we're still watching the the the shakira
game but yeah that's what we were kind
of afraid of for shakhri are now just
rook cc five and rook takes h5 it's just
going to be yeah or gc5 doesn't matter
what you do yeah king e3 here just
completely winning uh rook ending
with geoffrey
unhappy yeah f3 and why would he be
something very very strange
i think he's lost again unfortunately
yeah he carried something very very odd
there i don't really understand king
went to h6
he decided not to liquidate into a rook
ending which didn't really look all that
bad and just kind of
so he'll concentrate queens
and
shaq as lost as
uh fruit just collected all the pawns
yeah let's go to hikaru game guys right
that one is really hitting up right now
and they're both under 30 seconds
well i mean there's nothing to say uh
white has the attack and the material
looks like yeah it looks like white
should be in full control here uh if uh
if nothing so what if i just simply
repeat rook to d7 yeah gg7 you'll have
to play i mean you can play queen g4 i
guess so he includes queen e3 queen e4
which i think makes sense the king goes
to h6 and now he has to i mean you still
have to kind of pay attention to rook c1
threats right so
so quinto f4 is going to be met by king
to jesus why didn't he play rook to d5 i
don't know yeah
rook to d5 well in hx
oh
yeah i think he thought he was just
winning here with queen of four and then
he realized yeah okay okay he hasn't
released so he can still yeah ten
seconds though yeah okay this is ah but
you have rook to d5 no
he's gone he's going to offer that queen
trade again which now kikara absolutely
has because otherwise he queen
well okay rook c1 but yeah this is
actually a better by the way i'm not
going to take the b6 pawn
take the take on d1 and rook d6 take
pictures okay one okay one a four though
rookie one a4 yeah i think i think
i think we go king of three four and
then we we go with the king towards the
c6 square and that wins i assume so we
go king e3 rook f4
just king e4 rook of two king d5 i'm i'm
not stopping just anything straight yeah
um you know expressed to the c6 uh
square yeah i think king takes b6 once
king takes six appears on this one
even here i don't care
so king e4 rook f2 king d5 let's go
i don't know i don't know why we're
doing this i don't i don't
i mean he might still win but i don't
agree with this i think
we like we can we can very safely
abandon our entire king side once just
yell just
he does it this way but rook a2 still
exists i'm not sure why this is stronger
than what i was suggesting i really just
like group d4 i think
exactly an extra tempo yeah maybe with
the king on g6 you don't get to play g5
maybe
justifying the extra tempo
i think i think we're trying to
yeah i think rook of thoroughbred k2 is
the best choice here he goes okay to
first i oh wow okay so he just just goes
d3d4 here probably also very safely
winning because the two passers are
going to be way too strong
okay one even interesting because rookie
one really yeah okay six king d5 b6 it's
just going to be winning yeah it's very
hard to imagine how this is not winning
for
for linear yeah king d5
but one thing you cannot do you cannot
count hikaru out he's so tricky in this
type of situation yeah for sure
only 25 seconds left for linear and
still a technical task ahead of himself
well how technical is it
king d5
and king c6 will protect the people king
d5 and then we can actually trade the b
pawn for the a pawn go king c65 d6 we're
winning even that end game quite
comfortably in particular if we take the
a pawn on a2 so that f2 is not even
going to hang besides a so this is why i
like king d5 right now just cooking
defined by the way just to give you an
update fabiano right now is better yeah
5b is better
yeah five years better we go king of
five we don't even go a2 i think a2 is
making widespread helpful simpler
well i think i love b7 yeah i think b7
just wins yeah b7 we take on a2 rook
takes b7 legal king c6 exactly and he's
going and the g pawn is going to start
running
and we're you know this is a version of
this end game which should be kind of
comfortably winning and just the eyes
yeah well just as you pointed out the
rook on a2 is doing a fantastic job
just covering the one weakness in the
position the f2 and the king is
escorting the pawn this is easy yeah
this should be easy easier as it gets in
fact you might even be advised to you
can e2 ruby one rook c2 and then just go
d6 d5 d6 d7 yeah rook before interesting
yeah he wants to give a check this
yeah or even the six for e6 roxy [ __ ]
d5 and then we'll play rookie to next
move
it seems to be just completely winning
now there is a number of very very
comfortable options that should end the
game d6 yeah i mean
never a mistake just going rookie two
here is never going to be g5 has to be
played yeah g5 but
try 67
so d6
what if you get greedy and try to take
the pawn on h4 but you're not in time
right because d6 ghd7 and then g takes h
simply i'm not even giving up on h4 at
least not without a fight
ah d7 yeah yeah i just go to seven yeah
yeah i mean even if you win the ball on
h4 i think you'll lose
i'm not giving it up so easily yeah
right
yeah roxy for checking d5 and then if
the rule goes to cbon we go rg2 that's a
resignation and that's it let's move to
caruana right now yeah
the the last one running and yeah
there's been significant changes there
five
stabilized completely and now we have
sort of exactly the end game that
we were envisaging at one point where
white has this one pawn majority on the
king's side the queen side is completely
sealed off
and the question is whether you know
white can actually do anything with it
because black is kind of hamstrung and
i don't think sam has
any real counter play but he might have
just the
knight h695 might just be a draw now
because well the problem is rook to b3
right ah he provoked would be three rp3
might be a problem oh yeah yeah rugby
three rupee three needs to be played
yeah i mean you are giving up the d4
pawn but i mean activating that rock is
awesome
i think i think we always play rugby
three here i'm surprised it's taking him
this long honestly i think
you know it's
it's what he's been playing towards this
entire game
agreed also rook g4 is a draw first whoa
whoa rook two what's g6 ah now bcmg5
check this he wants to play
check here
but if he's winning i don't think he's
winning that no no but this is a very
strange decision this is a very very
shocking decision to my eyes yeah knight
f4 check i mean obviously the knight
takes h5 is going to be unplayable maybe
lose if you play knight h5 so right yeah
i don't really wait wait a minute wait a
minute
the rook is trapped knight takes e6 ah
no he's gone no he has gone bishop g5
sorry yeah i'm gonna say six king g's
i mean king g4 is also playable it's
yeah but i think h6 is safer with the
idea of king of seven we go king well i
do 98
yeah but i think we're happily trading
uh b7 for g4 in that agreed agreed uh
yeah that's a very very strange decision
by fabi
and uh he played king e2 yeah but the
issue is like even let's say i think he
does get to stabilize and not lose the
default like king king of something
he'll play knight g5 check knight of
three and he will stabilize but then
black will just blockade on e6 and how
how do you ever win this you don't i
don't think you do yeah i don't think
you do because the weakness of the
witness on d4 will always provide black
with enough counterplay you can even go
to king h5kg4 here maybe
just to you know generate additional
awkwardness
well can't i just like one day just put
my king on d3 and bring my knees down
like g7 which is also very logical
repositioning it on e6
yeah
solid also very very solid not only six
kingdom the more i'm looking i i don't
like the decision play rook there it's
just fine it's just very strange
yeah rook to b3
uh trading off the d4 pawn for the b7
pawn looks so much better than this yeah
i i don't know what would have you know
provoked provoke this decision it does
not seem right
the issue is you can't even attack the
pawn on b7 like you need to get to g6
and you don't really have squares that
get you to g6 like you can play what
he's playing but right i think you know
his dream here is like knight b2 a4 b6
c8d6
oh yeah yeah he's going now yeah this is
the plan now right this is the plan now
it goes to a4 it goes to b6 it goes to
c8
uh and and then if it lands on b6 it
becomes interesting a little bit
interesting again a little bit i don't
know
let's take a look at that are you in
time to get back with the king right now
yeah i'm king on g5 already a bit too
far yeah i'm i'm from i'm wondering this
is what peter is recommending everybody
knight a4 to b6 to c8 to d6
tying black down if the knight gets to
d6
you're not intentionally to defend with
the king so that might be a problem and
so christian is just thinking like if
you're not fast enough we're not giving
we're not guessing time no we're not
getting there in time uh
so yeah this this looks like maybe this
was sam might have gotten greedy with
his king g6 king g5 a bit too active
yeah
okay so let's get to that position with
the knight on d6 and put the knight on
d8
am i so
is that enough
yeah he is he's going towards towards
those types of setup setups like knight
b8 98
uh 96 checking g7 even this yeah exactly
as christian is suggesting even this
because the moment our king
starts running up yeah 96 94 will
provide plenty of counter play so yeah
just just go yeah king d7 96 98 or king
c7 even
yeah even this yeah he got with the king
on c7 and now the winning plan if it
exists will be connected with the idea
of getting that king that knight from d6
to f4
shifting shifting the blockading knight
from e6
and then hoping to invade with our king
but yeah it feels like even this is
holdable because of just how
how difficult it will be for for fabi to
uh make any progress while also
controlling the g4 square
five
so somehow he's got to get some kind of
a zuk's wong
where the king will approach the knight
on e6
yeah we can start
yeah but it just doesn't do anything we
can go king g4 king of three kings of
[ __ ] h5 but it just doesn't do very
much yeah he's done it another way he
wants he wants to play knight
f4 that's what i was suggesting but i
don't think it like i think once you
play neither four black just goes knight
g5 and says uh
yeah what's next what's next
all right i think this is still a draw
with decent defense
probably
okay so you're saying
you pass with it and he's done now
you're going to follow knight g5 now one
legendary
seven is not bad at all yeah just put it
on f5 remind bobby that once again
there's a deep one though there is a
pawn on d4 which you constantly have to
protect you pretty much never can afford
to give it up
right yeah christian christian has
uh ideas about this enemy no okay
christian has ideas no ideas about this
no yes plenty has plenty but the the
live action is sort of more important as
well exactly by the way the clock's uh a
factor at this moment
no no no no i don't think so
one minute and 16 seconds for sam one
minute and 10 seconds the problem is
they gain 10 seconds every time they
make a move and they're making a lot of
moves to get to where they want to right
it's interesting how uh in the in the
large shot that we're the live shot
we're watching on our screens how the
board just absolutely blends into like
the wood is the wood is just continuing
past the board yeah exactly it just
uh and yeah the glare the glare slightly
prevents us from seeing the clocks in in
[Music]
one minute and 32 seconds for sam one
minute and 10 seconds for fabian
but indeed nothing has changed it
doesn't seem like fabiano has enough
resources to create any sort of
imbalances
it's just very difficult to see how you
make any progress whatsoever which is a
obviously a large problem for fabi here
and there you see the clock times a
little bit more better
a little better without the glare there
56 seconds more clocks it almost feels
like a draw is
the fair result in this game sort of
yeah fabiano was better after he managed
to put that pawn on a5 in the opening
then he was much worse than he was
completely winning and now he finishes
in a draw
yeah it feels fair
yeah and uh the game we haven't really
announced the end of ended in a draw the
game between levon and mvl was kind of
an intricate intricate battle with the
positional pawn sacrifice that mvl uh
offered in the opening but it did end
peacefully
nice
that was actually a very keen battle
two victories thus far two draws and
this game will determine whether or not
we'll have three
it's becoming a bit awkward for sam
because i think
like if the king gets to g6 maybe it
does become very unpleasant but you
should be able to stop it because for it
to get to g6 it kind of needs to pass
through through the g5 square which is
uh kind of
fraught with danger right shall we say
but yeah
but
okay what if i give a check where do you
put the king in this question
i think f7 is safe enough yeah he's gone
92 uh and here yeah the issue is king of
seven king 597 check
uh kicks the kickstand king away so yeah
i don't think i don't think we can
actually make anything
can i go to h6
what does that do like
yeah probably nothing but yeah probably
not very much also
as things stand right now you can oh
yeah this is the way to get to h6
actually right if you want to get the
h67 king g5 96 and now king to h6 now
the question is can i just simply go
knight g7 yeah i think we should go 97
back yeah
i think we should go 97 back and we once
again remind well well okay okay okay
but then we go knight g3
and knight d6 knight f5 he didn't go to
h6 by the way
he went back to g4 yeah
so i think i think he's actually he's
actually passed
the move a little i think we may we may
have had this position with white to
move and now it's black to move knight
c7 aha knight to b5 yeah keeping for a
second there i was very excited about
knight f4 right no reestablished
blockade as of yet but 95 does generate
counter play
that's
a um
knight f4 knight b5
king g5 no knight takes d4 that doesn't
work i'm trying to get in with e6 check
and also a good position for my king
can't get both yeah i don't think i
don't i don't think this this this
happens
king to f4 now he's trying to he's
trying to kind of triangulate a little
bit trying to confuse sam but yeah you
can go 96 check we've had this position
king three and now i thought this was
just a repetition proposition but i
guess it's not no i think he's bobby's
still trying yeah he's still trying but
so
yeah the the resources are so depleted
and the black positions so so solid that
feels like it shouldn't be enough but
we'll see obviously there's no question
that uh the one thing he was heading for
this ending when he played that whole
rook takes g6 sequence
uh he he must have felt that he could
have forced the zugswang too yeah it's
it's just strange so the only thing you
don't want to do with black don't play
king g6 yeah and don't get into a king
upon end game that's just lost yes
that's on the spot hope hopelessly lost
yeah but that should be easy enough to
avoid right that that doesn't sound like
something that you
uh should be missing
exactly
so
knight to g7 by the way guys only one
games that shouldn't be that should be
never mind two we have lanier and
alireza both
yeah sam
by the way sam played that move a little
bit alacrity yeah
is clock becoming a factor or what
what's going on 10 seconds
good he's still he's still fine and
honestly i don't think it even matters
much where he goes but yeah whoa
e eight of all the squares you'd pick
so after king e3
you're going to go knight d8 kingdom
seven kings seven i should transpose
something we had earlier
it does it is just a simple
transposition sorry by the way he made
that move with seven seconds on the
clock seven okay not a lot
no
at this point obviously he's starting to
see some ghosts right probably yeah what
are those ghosts
yeah that he's worried about
king 28 king to f7 will he go for that
because if he's fine g6 as you guys were
mentioning yeah you have to stop yeah
you have to stop that king from getting
too good squares so yeah that's
something to be worried about yeah
fabi's doing a very uh good job
yeah a good job of kind of shuffling
back and forth now king d7 might already
be bad i'm not sure i think it still
might be okay yeah now we can play king
three and scare sam kind of seriously
but maybe not seriously well you scared
him into playing knight d8 as a kind of
uh
he realizes the knight is going to go to
d6 um
so yeah but even this yeah we we've sort
of achieved the maximum we we drove the
king to a seemingly
slightly sub-optimal square then back on
d8 and i still see absolutely no way
forward that's true yeah which is very
disconcerting it is after making all of
this wonderful progress to have not
achieved
anything near your desired dreams yeah
so if you go king of three i just simply
go back weirdly right uh
a draw seems inevitable
yeah i was going to yeah it's actually
it's actually somewhat relevant there
they are
16 moves away from a valid 50 move claim
wow wow
and kingdom goes away king d7 king e7
just uh
marking time
very very good idea i mean sam makes me
nervous watching him at the board
he's going
a little panic but now he uh built up
some time on his clock he has 39 seconds
right now
he looks i think he looks more fidgety
than uh you know the position demands
right but exactly he's still going to
make a draw i think i think is is going
to be fine in
in the end but
squishy bottom is that what the brits
say
when the when the football matches get
uh a little tense squeaky squeaky bomb
yes squeaky bum
king f7
so where's the progress bobby
that's the question
progress what progress
when you what is that progress that you
speak of yeah when you see your
opponents getting nervous
does does that bleed over to you peter
do you i think it should it should yeah
kind of improve your mood a little bit
by
by you kind of like it you like seeing
your opponent uh
getting off by the way now after king to
g6 it's a bit more difficult to get back
to where you are yeah i believe that is
e7 yeah we're still we're still kind of
safe enough because the king can not
really like the moment the king goes
away from e3 we just have 96 94 as a
source of very valid counterplay
because i think one of the
it's difficult to even achieve that but
one of the problems white has in this
position is if you win the b7 pawn
you're still a lot of jumps away from
attacking a6 and if you lose the d4 pawn
yeah that might be a problem yeah c5
becomes weak the d-pawn
is a is a defended passer that might be
problematic yeah so you risk losing
absolutely so
yeah
in terms of progress being made if you
trade d4 for b7 i think black is pretty
much always going to be by far the
happiest
the happiest side in that trade
and yeah the king is going back to g7
yeah sam says yeah not interested no
yeah i'm not venturing not venturing out
too far too far and by the way they're
closing in on that fifty move through
absolutely like ten more moves to go
exactly i think exactly tend to go yeah
yeah and sam was actually peeking at the
monitors in the playground
trying to figure out where 50 moves the
trade happened on move 66 so yeah 166
116 is the mark and they are at
108 right now
so uh so something has to be traded or a
positive five is six yeah e5 e6 has to
be played because nothing else really
moves in this position exactly and it's
kind of hard to imagine how you play
five or six here to be honest like right
in most cases it will just be a born
blunder right
six moves away yeah
seven
what
wants to bring it over to f4 again yeah
and the probably good idea not to leave
it on d80 if it gets right yeah i think
that would be you could get trapped yeah
that was actually a smart try by
fighting because if you if you kind of
sleep through it with blood right you
allow knight to four you know
might never actually get back to good
squares but
f5 is a good square c7 i thought it was
also a good square i like that b5
yeah 7 was a very good move sam is very
awake too well he's actually he's
claiming a three-fold i think he's not
he's not claiming 50 he's claiming a
three-fold i'm pretty sure with might
have five
this is a good thing no i think he he he
wants to know where the 50 move uh oh
you can also i think you can stop the
clock and ask the arbiter as well yeah i
think he is
yeah and this is something that is uh i
think this is something that people are
kind of generally reluctant to do but
it's very much
[Applause]
so it seemed to have been a question
rather than a claim yeah i think i think
you're allowed to actually stop the
clock and yeah it gets
it results in your opponent getting some
extra time but that's completely
irrelevant which is fine yeah which is
fine like you were
yeah and crisper just giving uh the
extra time to fabulous
[Applause]
yeah he's just gonna make a few more
moves and it will be
all decided peacefully uh
yeah okay so now five is saying would
you like to play 93 check knight c4 and
knight takes a five wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute uh
yeah why not or i mean why not are you
kidding me
is this suddenly a game i mean white
probably isn't really risking very much
because the pawn will be very strong i
don't think europe
but yeah i don't know i don't know why
we're introducing kind of new elements
into this equation but at this you know
late hour i think
i think fabi uh
was a little bit i mean here's the the
two minutes to say like doing this on
actual 40 seconds
i would advise against exactly okay so
what are we looking at king and king
uh i don't think sam is interested in
actually taking yeah he did he did
recheck which move it is yeah king g5
will be will be played i assume because
we're watching those bits
you're just simply not going to
calculate knight c4 at all are you are
you really going to take this pawn and
they'll allow uh you can try
he did i mean now that you played knight
e3 check i don't think you i mean you
can play knight c 2 i guess if you want
to if you want to still be kind of solid
you can play knight c2 here and
considering it's 115 if you want to draw
what if you're just playing king six
[ __ ] is six yeah just uh no give me
six
yeah okay
king six king is seven yeah i just stay
like this seven yeah if he wants to draw
knowing which move it is i think
actually like next move he will be able
to claim white probably never has enough
time to play e5 v6 the way to make sure
if iv6 doesn't happen on the next move i
think is to play knight c2
if we want to make sure that we make a
draw by claiming 15 we go knight c2
right now e6 is basically
probably losing louder yeah i think i
think e6 loses you you will not no
longer make a draw after that right you
can't really give up g4 by playing
knight f4 so what makes any move
you make any move in response and you
claim 50. yeah and this is what he's
done
he is not very excited about the ig of
spending to be picking up the a5 pawn
yeah
and and whatever [ __ ] he plays he's just
going to stop the clock claim 50 and
here it goes king e6 i think i guess
this is or maybe he wants to play yeah i
think maybe a couple more moves just to
be sure yeah i mean fabi's not playing
e6 anytime soon yeah you can play king
six now and if king g7 maybe not xd4 is
winning
yeah actually is that takes d4 a winning
attempt anyway like after king g5 maybe
maybe maybe you are supposed to play
knight for check 92 now not to lose
after king e6 yeah i don't like it i
don't want to calculate 94 king e5
honestly with white that would be
hilarious i think that would be a way to
lose yeah that would be a way to
occasionally lose i don't know if it's
actually losing but that would be a way
to at least introduce the option of
losing this game which i don't think
fabi would enjoy very much
whoa
okay and sam basically knows that he can
claim
but he also might be better now
and you can see it in his face there
that basically you know his play was to
claim somewhere around here but five is
artfully introducing the idea of winning
the game instead yeah and uh sam is
uh
i mean that's a serious attempt yeah i i
think white probably holds but he might
probably needs to make a cup a number of
only moves in response right yeah sam is
not interested in that on seven seconds
i think you can sort of there we go
finally the players have agreed
maybe with a slide in there yeah
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
what
was i trying to win or lose that at the
end that's never really a hundred
percent sure that was very very clear
yeah that wasn't very clear
who was attempting what exactly a nice
start for the round peter uh two
decisive games out of the five games but
all of the uh
all of the games we're entertaining but
first uh cubitique absolutely
special for today we got merch and uh
merch uh merge for today is this
beautiful uh polyester spandex uh blend
t-shirt features the uh saintly striped
blitz logo on the front as you can see
uh and on the sleeve the the club logo
uh it uh is offered for for in
styles for both men and women and is
available as most most of the things we
will be showing you uh during these
broadcasts at cubaticstl.com
so
do take a look at
the merch and here are the results we've
had two
uh decisive games alireza and lanier
sharing the first uh place there as they
defeated shakariar
and hikaru nakamura big setback for
hikaru there what was he doing it seemed
like
he had fought his way back to some
reasonable position and then gave it
right back hot potato yeah that seemed
like a very uh
strange game but yeah let's let's uh
round up this uh this round with with
christian and take a short break
well i have to say it was a great round
a good start tournament very tense start
to the tournament i didn't expect uh
nakamura to actually four under uh the
sword of a linear but unfortunately for
him he wasn't able to handle the middle
game allowing that move knight takes c5
just giving up the pawn was a huge
blunder and he was on the back foot
since then and this was uh the game
between fabiano and shanklin it was such
a tense affair very very intriguing
games i have to say
and we're actually going to go to a
break we'll be back shortly
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello and welcome back to
the show
the show that is we were kind of uh
caught on unexpectedly unawares there on
that one
hello everyone did us dirty
we are ready for round two
and uh the standings after round one we
have the same things are pretty
straightforward with only one round gone
you see the two people who won their
games with the white pieces they're on
top with two two points out of two a
bunch of draws
and the two people who have lost their
games uh tied from ninth at the bottom
there chakri are losing to alireza and
losing to the pairings for round two
that is the interesting bit and we have
a lot of very exciting pairings as usual
uh jan has the white pieces against mbl
there up top chakrier will be
playing against white against levon
hikaru plays against alireza sam is
white against
dominguez and jeffrey's white against uh
fabi i think uh hikaru's game yeah i was
about to see that for me a kind of a
marquee match up no question about it in
my mind at least and for her cardio
after losing uh the first round it's
kind of feeling one of the things i've
noticed uh peter in uh in our rapid and
blitz uh tournaments over the year years
are players who get out to a really good
start
in
the
rapid they come
out of the rapids go into the blitz with
a nice lead after all the the rapids are
worth two points yeah absolutely it's
it's very very good to do well in the
rapid and exactly uh
bringing joy to my heart it's not the
board that we're that we have on the
screen but our discussion of people you
know still being uh greenfield
aficionados and still playing uh
greenfield as their main weapon uh there
is a very interesting game in progress
in in round two there with
two very very serious greenfield players
facing off against each other and uh
uh in nipomnishi uh mvl and vl actually
abandoning his
new love the the
the queen's gambit accepted and going
back to his roots so to speak and jan
himself is
is a very very serious greenfield player
has played greenfield more or less his
entire life exactly so we are very
exciting times
and i do have that uh
this is kind of a flashback to the old
90s this is the way everybody used to
play it uh before knight f3 became a
thing well
both yes and no from the white side yes
the bishop c4 the sort of the classical
the classical gunfielders i always sort
of prefer to call it okay is very much
uh you know a flashback maybe even two
earlier times i think boris baskey was
arguably arguably the
the hero of of this line from the white
side and you know geller played it a ton
and smith's love played it and like
uh it dates back to the you know the
glory years of the soviet chess school
but the reply that uh mvl is playing uh
against jan and the the line that mvl
shows move b6 on move 10 is very very
modern very uh kind of cut cutting edge
because
people the idea of playing music should
be seven in these types of structures is
obviously very very well known it is
lies on the surface but
uh people used to think that you have to
prepare it by either playing knight a5
or perhaps taking on d4 because if you
play b6 in this position as uh as mvl
has done gta xc5 actually is a very very
serious move exactly uh which is why
yeah it was assumed that you can't
really play this because you don't
actually have immediate obvious
compensation after the gtxc5 but then at
some point people realize that
uh the very forcing variations which
begin by dc5 queen c7 are probably
playable for black right
and the attention very much shifted from
those positions
towards the kinds of positions uh
exactly like the one that they are
playing right now where
white says
i will just play quietly i will play
rook c1 queen g2
and then eventually it very much shifts
towards as gasser is you know preparing
for my next word
yeah the h pawn is about to start
marching marching down the board and
it generates a tremendous amount of
problems for black surprisingly
and
will be very interesting to see how mvl
treats this at this position i always
love a peter when you have two
specialists playing
uh their
thematic opening so when you have two
great grunfeld players sitting down i'm
always curious to see what one grunfeld
player is going to do against another
just the same
uh
thought if you have two great night or
players going head to head it's always
interesting to see where they think
uh there are issues and where they try
to prod i can say from from my personal
experience i've
not often but i have over the course of
my career tried kind of
daring people to play the grunfeld
against me and people more often than
not would accept accept
and then i would just sit there like on
the floor thinking okay i can play a
variety like i can play about eight
systems against this now because
obviously i've studied this opening from
the other side my entire life and i
can't choose and i get very confused
like the last time i did this i was much
worse by move 15 with white so yeah i've
my personal experiences of this were not
as positive as all that okay now having
said that we do have cd and i am
expecting yeah
of course
we were about to get into this idea that
white should be pushing his h pawn and
try to make pretenses that uh
black's king can come under
i think c64 is an indication that maybe
he wants to play queen d6 rather than
the six but you know
the choice he played it rather quickly
take our viewers few uh through this
position what is it that white is trying
to achieve peter what is it that black
uh wants
black generally would like to play
something like windy six and then
perhaps start just trading everything
along the c file there is not very much
in the way of uh you know aggressive
counterplay here for black available not
at least at least not in the beginning
but if you get to play the queen g6
knight a5 and then you start just
trading everything down
you very often get a very playable
position bishop b5 is a
it's a quirky move but it's very useful
in all these types of positions because
you're kind of
sidestepping
the knight a5 count to play it still
happens as we as we see uh in the game
right now it still happens very often
but queen d3 was
actually no f3 was played uh
so we are in in expectation of knight a5
happening we're putting the bishop on
on a different square
and we're very much inviting a7 a6 which
is pretty much never played i think
because it just softens up the black
queen side so much the opponent b6
becomes a target in so many different
positions that
i think a7 a6
you
in most cases it's just going to be
unattractive yeah well like just to put
it down it just drops back to d3 one of
the one of the indications of
why you don't necessarily want to play
a6 even if it comes with a tempo is the
queen on b4 will it jump on b6 so you
don't necessarily want to do that are
you trying to achieve
which bishop do you want to open up
would you want to play f5 and 5 pretty
much never works
i think this this is extremely unlikely
for that yeah
there's there's a number of issues with
it yeah e594 is a kind of a quiet
positional issue because yes you have
the g5 square but the knight on the four
will challenge it very very well you
might also just lose by force to some
kind of immediate d45 in some positions
so you just want to play queen d6 trade
trade the rooks on the h pal and
basically just go into a balanced ending
from white's point of view what would
uh
i have a past pawn right shouldn't i be
playing
rook takes c8 and d5 and d6 d5 does sort
of wake up some of the pieces which
currently aren't doing very much in
particular the bishop on g7 i think
uh the response to 26 is likely to still
be h2h4 i think okay there's also bishop
f4 which kind of forces maybe forces a
strong word but a3 is not such a bad
square i don't know if we should be
actually forcing the queen to go to a3
because it doesn't really look you're
never worried about the d5
i am but as a greenfield player i feel
that you know my opening should somehow
you know uh
not fall yeah
due to one lousy past pawn going up the
board because once again like the moment
you play g5 here you actually do give me
counter play which just did not exist a
moment ago like eg5 vd5 a6 or 8585 take
on c1 and then a6
uh
there is now like if it gets to d6
very often i will be lost but while it's
on d5 i still have yeah i mean here you
will be able to play bishop c6 if i play
a6 so maybe i do it in the first way i
do it without trading on c1
but
straight away i recall and yuri it was a
game
between magnus carlsen
and
jan where jan was on the black side of a
groomfeld that was played in
norway chess
and
magnus played
some kind of a model game where he just
got this deep on
going uh very very early by the way we
do no we don't have uh
much action yeah uh so you're saying
that the d-pawn is not your big fear no
it is it is but i would like to prepare
it a little bit further because i don't
think black has much in the way of
counterplay yet and i think
uh let's say if we allow the entire
trade on the like rooksy one roxy one
rook c8 happens somehow those positions
still aren't entirely equal you're still
going to be a bit worse in all of those
types like 26 h4 let's say we just like
completely ignore what black is doing
rook c8 h5
okay we still haven't equalized i don't
think with black hmm
despite everything but christian has
sharper positions for us to enjoy
this is exactly what nepo is trying to
do by the way he's playing extremely
quickly he has 26 minutes on his clock
and envy are only 20 minutes so
definitely some pressure from the white
side in that one some more pressure from
the white side in this game between
jeffrey sean and caruana in this
position jeffrey could have simply
played the move d3 and tame the position
as it is knight takes c3 unfortunately
doesn't work for black because queen to
b3 and if you do have to retreat on d5
you're starting to feel quite awkward
because i have a lot of pressure on d5
you cannot move the knight from d5 f7 is
hanging this gives white tremendous
initiative now after the move d3 black
can just simply play the movie shot to
g4 and the position would be tame d4 was
wise choice e takes d4 and not take back
on d4 but bishop to g5 now we're
starting to see a very tactical melee
ensuing rook takes c1 queen take c1 you
have to be careful because if you do
play the move f6 knight takes d4 is a
huge alternative just simply opening up
the bishop on g2 with tremendous
consequences you do not have time to
take on g5 bishop takes d5 and now we
see despite the fact that you have some
sort of a luft it doesn't really matter
f7 square will be controlled after queen
to e8
that's a checkmate in one move you
cannot do that and if you do have to go
king to h8 well unfortunately after
knight takes e6 your position just
crumbles now let's take a look at what
else black can do in the position after
queen takes e1 queen to d6 seems to be
the right approach knight takes d4 once
again this is the key open up the bishop
on g2 knight takes d4 and if you do take
back on d4 bishop to e6 solidifying the
control in front of your isolated queen
spawn the square d5 actually gives black
the advantage
fortunately for white after knight takes
d4 i don't have to take it i can start
with the move rook to d1 this is a
tremendous move i want to take on d4
with the rook and pressure the knight on
d5 the best move in the position and the
only one equalizing right now for black
would be to move bishop to h3 wild stuff
potentially happening in this game guys
of course you cannot take on h3 because
knight to f3 would win on the spot and
now we have to simplify the position
while stuff white is uh calculating
potentially has calculated this or knows
it from home it does seem like fabiano
played the move queen to d6 and we might
be headed towards this knight xd4 and
rook to d1
wild variation only 18
minutes for fabiano though so he's
definitely trying to remember
potentially his preparation jeffrey
shawn with 24 minutes on his craft
thank you christian for that peter
you're familiar with that bishop h3 i
think it's before it's uh it's a like
i'm familiar with the theme but not not
uh with the exact position
that would be a remarkable sequence that
after knight takes d4 knight takes d4
rook to d1 yeah i think
h3 uh because i think uh
you you have to uh
state very empathically that see the xd4
hp6 it's not that black
uh solves uh his problems completely
black is instantly i think quite
seriously better yeah hp6 uh queen d7
with uh the knight on d5 is extremely
strong cannot be challenged anymore and
yeah white is struggling to equalize
here
exactly so if yeah rook one on the board
uh pretty sure that jeffrey uh jeffrey
has been aiming for this particular
position from
from the get-go and yeah bishop h3 you
you do need to play that because if you
play this b6 here allow rook takes d4
your pieces are still
very very vulnerable to all all kinds of
c3 c4 threats and you're just huge by
the way guys rook to d1 is on the board
exactly exactly and we're we are
expecting bishop h3
um i see a position like this or a whole
variation where the players are actually
playing quite quickly
and i go wow this is really really
really great
and then i see that
the opponent's not delaying either and
it's like how deep are
these top guys preparing peter i mean it
is yeah it is quite remarkable how well
i mean and jeffrey jeffrey in particular
jeffrey is a very very well booked up
young man and
uh
you have to you have to be very uh
careful uh on the black side against him
but yeah bishop iii still still solves
all of our issues and i think it's a
findable move because
again because of knight f3 check is so
uh
so obviously in your face right yeah
for a second there i was even wondering
how white equalizes here but my
assumption is rookie for bishop g2 king
queen c6 queen e4 is still fine even
though white will have to give up a pawn
there temporarily uh the the bishop
against night end games generally just
end
i mean you're never better here with
black i assume like 26 take stakes and
then maybe a4 or something and
with the rook c4 to follow and yeah
but still clearly clearly it's not
clearly black is always going to be
completely fine here i agreed agreed
agreed uh fabiano has to find bishop
pleasure right now right
but i would i would bank on him i would
bank on him finding it because yeah the
the other moves just are very very
unimpressive and then the other thing
about these types of variations that are
a little bit off the beaten track is
that
the position is actually even
but usually one side cannot deviate at
all they have to find all of the only
moves so to speak uh just how bad is it
if you go knight to c6 bishop h3 right
now
right now instead of horrible i would
think yeah
hang on
well the five queen of fate i guess is
your plan yeah yeah and you're you're
trying to play bishop six get the bishop
to e6 as fast as possible um
yeah
less less horrible than i assumed but
still
might be horrible though right queen
bible rugby five as well like might be
trying to trying to establish b6 like
ruby five in particular i think might be
extremely annoying
just trying to keep your queen side
developed exactly and then the h6 the
bishop will drop back to f4 or yeah
it's still passive it's annoying it's
very very annoying the question i had
was this
one no no no hold on bishop no how do i
get knighty to check in
no i don't get an id two no you don't
know 93 loses to rook d4 yeah
unfortunately this is an important
detail but it just loses straight away
like you just resigned to rook before
here
unfortunately for uh for black yes and
knighted to check also it doesn't work
at all agreed so yeah the choices
between something passive like the line
that christian just suggested perhaps
knight g6 i didn't even consider that
move for some reason but it's probably
stronger than bishop b6
or finding bishop h3 but i think bishop
h3 is findable i would assume it's it's
a move that you are very very capable of
seeing let's take a look at one of our
tournament leaders linear dominguez this
that's not very very very unexciting uh
sam shankland uh on the white side of a
rather boring position well a shakriar
yeah this is this is a weird one where
uh a trump which could potentially be
very very interesting and very exciting
like move four there was a very very
interesting turning point
because after c4 you can definitely i
think
if i can if i'm allowed to plug my own
material here i think my core says e5
here and i think after e5 you did a
chess book or something like this
variation i was i was forced to to to
finally for the first time in my life at
the the right they made you work not
only did they make me work they make me
work on the trump which i've been
avoiding for like the last 25 years and
so
i will i will i will never forget them
for it oh my goodness for you so you you
so you were recommending in your chest i
think i think
75 here is very playable if i remember
correctly and instead uh
levon went for something that is
extremely solid and he's probably fine
now but why not have fun if you can have
fun exactly and how dare he not be
familiar with your course that calls
himself
that is really that's really uh
all right the question for uh for you
peter do you know the counts gambit
what
uh i i'm very very bad with opening
names
no no no this is his this is my his
variation his special
opening name so after bishop g5 knight
e4 okay bishop to f4 okay just a second
hold on let the the the people have got
bishop to g5 say it again christian 94
yes bishop f4 yes and e5
whoa
is it a thing it is it's
his thing
okay
i analyzed it maybe 10 years ago with
the romanian olympic team
and we realized this complete garbage
but it was just the entirety of the
romanian olympic team yeah
in a rapid game quite quickly with black
okay nice
because you know bishop takes c5 d6 by
four g5 and you just
continue going like that okay
wow g3h550 yes h5 yeah we're we're not
stopping for anything yeah but h3h5 h5
yeah here we go
speaking of fun yes i mean somebody's
having fun maybe and there's a cute trap
so right take on e5 with the pawn okay
now i go d5
and 86 square f6 actually exactly
[Laughter]
all right
all right oh my goodness and you're
x-raying f2 as well oh dear oh dear i'm
having i'm having horrible flashbacks to
all the all the eric rosen videos even
though it's sort of unrelated but
wow okay how did guys study wow
oh
wow
i just i i'm just want to know the
refutation that's uh that that will work
for me that's coming in uh his uh second
chessboard course there you go
and uh finally oh well we're actually
where we're back so we missed one what
was the one we missed hikaru's yeah uh
let's check in on farouza and nicara for
just a moment and they played this very
very slow uh it started as what i
assumed would be some kind of a slav ish
thingy and then yeah he went just g3
here which is not
something you do very often when you've
started with e3 on move two but right
still still a kind of a double
fianchetto uh type position which
i mean seems kind of finely balanced and
then it became very much a ready
structure now with other as a pushing g4
and taking with the pawn
uh eventually uh here i i guess rook d4
maybe he was worried about 95 because
normally i think you would like to take
with the rook but i think maybe 95 works
right
by the way guys fabiano hasn't played
the scene whoa
he's down to his last 10 minutes right
now are you sure 95 works peter ah
just now he played queen to e6 uh sorry
yeah let's go let's go back to fabiano's
game but obviously in this game fabio is
now in a very very significant amount of
trouble just play the move queen to e6
but
bishop takes d5 there should be five i
think he wants to play queen e1 rookie
one and 96. and no no i think 96 you're
kind of lost i think he wants to play
bishop e6 but he should be six okay hold
on uh that's just bad but
let me catch up with you so you're
saying bishop defense only move you i
think you resign either way anything
else yeah and i think i think 96 bishop
e3 is
terrible i think you you don't recover
from that i don't think you ever develop
your queen side so don't i have to play
bishop yeah we should be singing should
be seven rook b8
but then bishop e4 i guess
and like it's it feels like it should be
borderline winning bishop takes d5 is on
the board and let's see how he responds
this is awesome yeah it's just very
queen e6 looks very surprising to me
because i thought i thought bishop h3
was a move that you could spot and like
the the issue with bishop h3 is just
realizing it's an option the moment you
see it exists yeah you just play it
without thinking well it's developing
yeah it solves all of yourself and
everything else
um you kind of intimated uh
as we were going through uh round one
that
fabi's misfiring yes and he has been
misfiring for for a bit for a while and
this is kind of a symptom it's it's
queen e6 bishop takes d5 and it's
obvious that white's on top white's
having
the fun here because if you did
something like queen takes rook takes
and just kind of go into some kind of
horrible there should be three
yeah seven as well but yeah and like
yeah never kidding yeah you're never
getting out of uh the troubles that
you're just it's just absolutely
absolutely horrible yeah that there's
only
so let's go with this bishop to e6
yeah let's let's take a look at that
other line so we take on e1 we go push
p6 if not for bishop takes b7 this would
have been playable so we should be seven
rugby a8 now i can take on d4 and go d5
yeah but that's probably not enough yeah
that's that's i think best case scenario
by this point for black yeah we go
bishop d7 we go f6 i don't think we lose
that one i think that one we actually do
save
right we're yeah actually we're kind of
relieved
we got a bishop of opposite color
but i think we were just stopping here
should be four
and say bishop e4 this is where which b4
is just so unpleasant because we've
taken away all the good squares 95 from
b1 we might be losing by fours can't
break maybe maybe not yeah maybe we can
actually play knight b5 that's it might
be extremely critical rugby one [ __ ]
play two
and then put it on c4 rugby 2 bishop c4
brook b4
rook c8 yeah if this if this holds that
maybe the entire thing is not as bad
right let's go back but yeah and by the
way we do have knight e6 on he's gone
i'm really really shocked i'm really
surprised by all of this because this is
just so obviously like any square i mean
even before honestly
it's not bad
bishop f4 using the fact that you can't
take and just plonk it on d6 and
oops
i agree plunk it on d6 that is the dream
square
stops anyway
such strange decisions from fabio yeah i
i am
honestly kind of shocked by all of this
uh
look i i gotta go with fabi just a
moment uh
i mean i'm trying my darndest
to develop so let's go rook b1 rook to
b1 no no no that takes a four maybe this
one we don't lose maybe bishop four
isn't the best honestly let's put it on
either e7 or e3 i don't know which one
you like best yeah i'm not sure either
yeah
help me
choose one i like a three honestly okay
i think e3 is good
because 97 i can ah in 97 i have a bush
before that was my point i wanted to
kind of invite an ic7 and then
that is funny that's nicely done uh
you i don't know it's just tricky it's
just very very ugly i i really really
hate this by the way just to give you
the computer's assessment it's plus two
right now
not surprised in the slightest
completely winning objectively yeah wow
yeah
honestly and what knowledge number are
we looking at i mean what are you seeing
right now not that it matters
when do you see fabiano i mean one of
the things about fabi's opening play
throughout the years has been his
extraordinary
um
knowledge of the overseas doesn't have a
bad position
after 20 moves or even a terrible
position as we're seeing right now uh
let's go to some of the other games here
as we uh again i wanted to carl
gh4 by the way
which is
perhaps also an indication of how he
feels about his position paige out of
bobby fischer's uh
uh benoni h5 h4 just gh here saying that
yeah okay i'm i'm not that worried
actually i kind of like it because well
it it will take some winning
time to win this pawn
yeah i mean king h1g1 currently a2 maybe
is hanging i'm not sure we can
completely ignore it i could
make an argument for ignoring it even
here like king h1 82 roxy
um that looks a little contorted though
doesn't it well you'll have to run back
in h1 h1 if you take i go roxy too i
think queen a5 is strictly the only move
and we can go okay one rook takes a
seven
i don't think i'm that unhappy okay fair
fair fair
so
king sorry king h1 invites one is one
option we can also of course we can go a
to a4 here just to not have to think i'm
assuming his idea it was that he wanted
25 h5 i think that's the yeah yeah i
think that's the idea not to
end up with the knight on f3 really
pressuring the the d4 pawn
queen a5 so
rook
yeah i kind of hate the c2 square for
the rook like i i'm i'm using it under
advisement you know you really really
would prefer not to but i might have to
because 94
then you might actually get after my
queen side like you will take only four
and then you will both pick up both a2
and b3 and this is like much less
obviously like
i would prefer not to lose the entire
class okay so we're not happy we're not
proud
of our rook at the moment but it does do
useful things
it defends so what do we think about the
same game of the queen h5 takes takes
knight of
three i'm uh
i'm not sure yeah it's so
confusing i guess black is fine but
i am prepared to go rook g1 g4 here
which means that the knight probably
doesn't stay on a four
very easily
it's a weird one i don't know it's it's
weird i i
yeah i haven't come to a clear
conclusion king h1 is myself king h1 is
on now the question is why do you play
after rook c5 rook c5 rook f5 and you
just tried that so that's a that's a
good uh good source of counter play as
well you know knight h5 knight f4 and so
on and so forth and he played it roxy
five rook five and taking h5 yeah this
is very strong yeah i missed it i mean i
missed the road cliff you don't have a
light square attacker so my rook on f5
is going to live forever yeah yeah that
is that is a very very good choice by
the reza and you do have to wonder
like gh you know if it comes off it's a
very very uh interesting kind of
ambitious idea which you
you enjoy playing but when you are
compromising compromising your kingside
very very seriously and you have to you
have to honestly you have to go back
perhaps to even move 17
because
yeah queen b7 check
uh
why aren't we playing queen f3
i understand it's maybe not such a fun
end game if if the end game is what it
will be
but honestly allowing that queen sort of
full reign on the long diagonal would be
very counter-intuitive to me i i guess
maybe what hikaru the problem here yeah
for for white i don't see it yeah i
think i think we're quite happily
bringing that king actually to e2
pawn
[Music]
my guess would be his plan was to play
king g1 then to play 92 and then perhaps
to play queen f3 and if the trade
happens we have a knight on f3 instead
of the of the king which is maybe useful
yeah but
yeah it's a it's a curious one
also why not queen of three here
uh it's certainly a safer alternative
um
ambitious play very very ambitious yeah
rook c5 is a good move by the way for
sure yeah rook c5 and what surprises me
is that he's putting so much pressure on
hikaru's clock
you would expect hikaru to be up on time
in every single game he wasn't that much
up on time in the game against lanier
and once he got the worst position then
he fell behind on the clock we're seeing
exactly the same scenario playing guy
out right now only 12 minutes for hikaru
and 16 minutes for ali reza ali reza is
showing great form so far
okay we'll keep an eye on that one i
just wanted to flash to the game between
nepo and vl
because i saw something that's a little
bit surprising
i think we had both come to this
beautiful mutual agreed
understanding that we weren't going to
see the movies
no but it's it's connected with a very
concrete idea right now because we're
we're forcing the bishop back and then
we're playing on knight c6 which has a
dual idea of first of all simply
attacking the pawn on d4 very uh you
know very straightforward creativity but
also just as you were indicating it does
generate the idea of playing queen
before which will
currently with the way pieces are
probably take the queens off which is
something that black was very much an
achievement yeah so uh yeah jan does
this which is
keeping the game alive
but giving up the bishop bear and uh
mvl very logically extremely quickly
goes a6 a5 hinting at bishop a6 uh
because f3 and e4 pawns
do a very very good job of you know
uh controlling the bishop on b7 so
giving it squares is very very useful
and kung g5 queen is queen g8 is a very
clever idea as well i think
uh
reminding mvl that there is opponent h4
meaning that let's say if you play queen
e5 check which is what i assumed he
would do right uh we can play maybe even
queen f6 and the pawn h4 is hanging i
was trying to calculate while we were uh
while we were discussing other things i
i like queen b5 better than q6 because i
want to stop which basically i don't
want to calculate space 6 i see so i
thought queen b5 and
if you take on h4 i take on b6 i am
never entirely happy with white here
giving up the pawn on h4 because it does
generate some potential count to play
against my king
later in the game seven h4 yeah but if
but if i'm winning the a5 pawn and the
bishop won't be say yeah or maybe this
is clever yeah maybe this just makes a
draw yeah that's what i'm saying you can
bail out thanks to this uh maybe this
just makes a drama yeah this is a very
good explanation and in the end uh uh
jan does something quite interesting he
goes knight c3 here saying
uh if the queens have to come off
please sir would you like to take on g5
yeah improving my structure tremendously
and uh
some end games will still be very
unpleasant for black but you have to you
have to do it kind of move by move
because queen g5 hg
let's say right huh that's right or or
rook c7 or rook c like i would very much
like to
knight b5 right
this knight might uh appear maybe
a4
not against rook d8 though right because
i have rook c1 rogue d4 in reply yeah
even that maybe is not like
i was saying as
if you played rook c6 or excuse me or
rook c7 i was i was thinking that
against this knight a4 might be very
very annoying here yeah yeah that's the
move i missed actually i was calculating
everything else
interesting rg8 seems to be uh sensible
but we can continue quietly but now we
go rook c7 i guess right right king 3
rook dc8
and now we're here
i think if i manage to double on the c
file i'm not going to be struggling too
much yeah because of my outside like
yeah so long as i don't you you just
stopped me from getting in my knight a4
uh nicely done but you were just the way
i'm 86 back he's just
he went back what
whoa that's very strange play by mvo
that is he went back to d6 after knight
c3 that is quite shocking yeah so the
idea is that if you go knight b5 i just
simply go queen before i guess
before i guess and saying that your
knight is
almost trapped i in queen to e5 you have
f6
and
tactically you're hanging on like that
well well sorry i'm missing something
queenie
after knight b5 knight b5 queen b4 queen
to uh e5 okay i get it and if i go queen
e5 check roxy five i suppose but then i
take four even here yeah right and then
i take on e5
b6 this is like the bishop the bishop e
97 rook c7 you you know occasionally
this will be unpleasant maybe not in
this particular case but occasionally
this gets very unpleasant or knight b5
is on the board by the way knight b5 is
on the board right now
queen yeah it has to be queen before
otherwise previously no queen d7 i just
went queen d7
queen this i am so confused by all of
this
sometimes our guesswork is just
okay but wait a minute he is
65 f6 and then rook c7
how is that position
we take on c7
there's a couple of moves right i don't
want to see you like bishops i don't
like giving up on b60 okay
we've got to trade yeah i think this is
fine for black now but now black
suddenly is doing great right 96 well
great great i'm not sure i'm not sure
because i do go rook c1 and i solidified
that knight with e5 so yeah she wants a
seven yeah it's still it's still
actually very very move by move
you have to be if we go like rook a8
here
or
okay
and it you like you say it's just move
by move and we we hope that our eventual
passer on the queen side will provide us
with enough counterplay but yeah this is
extremely extremely concrete but you
have to be careful so i can actually
seven rook c7 you go k7 i go e5 yeah how
is this position i have no idea i'm not
if you go b5
maybe i have knight b7 and that might be
problematic knight b7
fun this is not fun at all yeah
very very interesting and from this
position that end game that we've been
looking at folks
all stems from the move queen e5 check
from the current position f6 rook c7
uh
double
double edged stuff this is great
[Music]
i love
these forcing lines and how
do you ever find that you get go down a
rabbit hole and you keep sinking deeper
and deeper and deeper and then you come
to conclusion that you
you don't know what's going on
yeah it happens but i think in this
particular position you are very like if
you see this idea you you become very
attracted to it because
your alternative might just be knight c3
because f7 f6 if we just go back one
move here 27 just the current position
f6
wins the p like if you do nothing f7 f6
will win the knight because we don't
have any squares on the fifth
can't really play e5 or d5 here none of
those moves actually do anything apart
from blundering the knight as well
so your choices here are you know knight
moves knight c3 or knight a3 which looks
even more artificial and we've just come
from c3 so we're not we're not very
enamored with that idea
or alternatively you actually spot that
you have the screen e5 connected with
rook c7 because otherwise queen e5 is
just a blunder once again clear
um so yeah i don't know how easy it is
to even spot this idea but if you do
spot it you probably go for it because
it does look interesting and then you
find yourself going down this rabbit
hole of well he's called knight c3 uh so
he's either he either either
disagreed with our assessment of this
idea or he just didn't see rook c7
so queen d6 are you just going to
and by the way as we take a look at our
grand chess tour standings we've got
these two players mvl and lavonne both
trailing wesley so by
as you were mentioned earlier three and
a half points if they finish in the top
half they will leapfrog wesley and a
very big result from either player puts
them in the driver's seat absolutely i
mean everything will still be decided in
the sinkhole cupboard because yeah
there's plenty of points up for grabs in
the central cup so
no
whatever happens here uh
nobody will be able to put
you know the the branches to overall
standings on lockdown but
right
so by the way knight c3 and 26 back by
by mvl as expected mvl is uh saying so
would you like to so what do you what do
you like to repeat here yes sir
and this is where i have also tried
queen e5 check and trying to go for that
other
ending
i think d6 yeah i think it's less
attractive in particular because like
dake's takes i might even consider
playing bishop c6 straight away just to
take away all of those squares all
together and just then
i will start switching there might be
five and therefore yeah rook d6
b5 yeah knight e2
yeah it's still annoying
our bishop is so well controlled by
those you know
wave breaker pawns on f3 and d4 that
wave breaker
yeah bishop b7 rook b6 maybe yeah it's
it's still very annoying yeah it's still
extremely annoying no i i think we have
to go to that first game please hikaru
against because it's getting wild okay
this was where we just saw that move
rook c5
hikaru
wants to use the g-file and by the way
down to his last seven minutes right
last seven seven minutes yes knight h5
defends g7 but also
prepares bishop takes rook takes kind of
a cute move here by
a2a3 which is a
very artful way to uh protect our queen
side from you know having to think about
queen takes a two yeah we should takes
h4 rook cf1 played very quickly um
i like the idea of including g7 g6
somewhere so that we don't have to think
about like i would like to free up my he
does it
yeah i would like to free up my knight
from you know having to calculate all of
this and i would like i would like to
have it on f4 eventually so yeah g6 i
think black is just very firmly in the
driver's seat here
knight to e4 yeah 94.
interesting that he played rook f1 prior
to playing 94 because he could have
arguably he could have done this on a
previous move right
um so we go knight of four i assume
right queen somewhere either three or g4
let's just get rid of this guy this
guy's a little okay i'll put it back on
e7 i'm not really that opposed
to this and
i'm
going to try to make i'm going to i'm
going to include queen b7 somewhere i
think
he's going to start with bishop e7 when
it seems yeah it looks like it looks
like he's just dropping it back straight
away sorry um he did not after knight e4
he didn't play another four yet i think
it's a sensible idea because if cringy
happens here he will have the option of
rook for
which might be a useful one so he is
preserving as many as many of his
options open as possible yeah by the way
i'm getting this
very unpleasant feeling that my bishop
on
b2 is actually not doing anything the
problem with bishop c1 can i just simply
take on a3 yeah i think maybe now
you see the training's been working
g5 i'm not sure how well it works
because i have bishop g5
winning a very important tempo and if
the rook just goes somewhere i have
rookie won and you might regret
having doing that to your pieces you
know having captured the pawn
uh you were you were about to mention
queen b7 slipping in a queen b7
somewhere without i think you you we
need to wait clearly we need to wait for
the queen to depart from g2 exactly
exactly so bishop e7
expecting
well f4
no can't be no bishop c1 is actually a
very clever move i have to say knight g3
not
very pleased with myself yeah
but yeah i can understand why you're why
you're i was about to try to land on c6
and on a very good day getting you know
knight g3 is on the ball yeah yeah
uh i hate the weaknesses that g3 takes
h4 left behind
for me
by the way we do have a result
shaq
shakriar and lavon we didn't pay too
much attention not too much it was a
very quiet game and intended in a in a
very logical looking this was the trump
yeah the trump ended up all we learned
was uh the count uh
gambit
well we did learn something we did well
that was very good you know yes
um
so again we have this uh very
heavyweight matchup between uh
jan and mvl
ikaro just played this move night
so how was the position after this move
knight to g3 do you have to take on g3
right now
is f4 f5 some sort of uh
an initiative for white in this position
if you allow me to do that like for
example you go rook to g5
obviously f4 can not be played not
immediately because
three wins on the spot
but
can i prepare somehow this idea of f4
can play with c1 now bishop c1 yes yeah
you're kind of letting me get in all the
groovy moves i've
been attempting here
i mean i would still prefer black here
but it's not that like it doesn't seem
like uh it's it's too much i think in
part due to the fact that the queen on
a6 is
not really participating in the game so
it's actually five how are you going to
respond to that
rook to e5 let's say rookie five
okay okay
um
maybe queen f3
well i was i wanted to go all the way
going to go down the diagonal i just
didn't know how far it was going to go
down the diagonal
um
so knight to f4 now knight to f4
now we drop back to f3 and we played
bishop c1 next move right so
i was hoping i i i tickled the tempo out
of you but now i'm not so sure anymore
uh who's winning the tempo knight h3 do
i have ideas of knight you have some you
have some
95 ideas
knight f5 yeah you could do that but
like i'm i'm not sure you will enjoy the
like i will just take on a five with a
rook play queen b7 check and claim that
i'm slightly also knight takes f2 no no
so he just took on g3 and and played
b6b5 so he is sort of opening uh opening
things up on the queen side to to
generate additional problems
fg very quickly played of course by
hikaru and b6b5
this looks like it should be sort of
manageable for white the queen on a6 is
still kind of out of play
i'm torn between the idea of taking on
f5 and spoiling the structure a little
bit or actually playing g3 g4 to try and
uh you know win the fight over the f
file like g4 rook of one rook f1
b take c4 b take c4
and then queen f3 next move against most
things
and start generating some counter play
like this it still feels like black has
the healthier position yeah for sure
structurally you know i have more
weaknesses to attack
it feels like a car was still on the
back foot well what about the other
variation which also you have
ef and let's just
if you want to
help me
can i take on a3 now
clever can i be extremely greedy but you
take on b5 maybe yeah he did play g4
he did go for four from my idea yeah bc
i think he goes b takes e4 i think you
pretty much never take the g pawn and
seems i think the reason he's thinking
is he could include queen f3 right now
maybe but
it feels yeah it feels unnecessary right
queen f3 is not going away at least as a
threat
yeah and queen f3 is extremely annoying
because it will
pretty much force black to allocate
resources to protecting the f7 pawn
because he pretty much never playing a
five you're pretty much never playing f6
because all of that softens your king
side that's a bit a bit too much
so you will have to dedicate some uh
some important resources to protecting
f7
christian so how is the end game after
let's say rook to d7
e5 okay he wants the e6 square for the
this is clever queen this is clever he
wants queen e6 yeah so we play queen f3
queen e6 and we play i guess bishop c1
because we need that bishop to be in the
game right but i don't like the square
f3 for the queen i want to put the queen
on e4 yeah also fair
we can do it straight away even yeah
right
let's try to go queen e4 queen e6
and again this bishop needs a life right
yeah it needs to be it needs to be at
least somewhat active but yeah he's gone
bishop see why she won straight away
without any of the queen moves
once again understandable this is the
move that we can't really do without so
he's preserving both options for the
queen he is not committing to any one
square
and by the way the character of the game
between nepo and mvl has changed
dramatically because mvl uh played
excuse me nepo played this move d5 and
the pawn a very thematic sacrifice
you're going to give up the d-pawn and
then you're just going to go uh e5 close
the bishop on b7 and now
at the position we currently have on the
board white has an option they can take
on d5 recapture the pawn this is not
happening no or knight to b5 which makes
the most sense in the position i in the
square d6 as well as potentially just
playing the move knight to d4 that's
going to close the [ __ ] bomb b7 and
potentially open up the situation where
white could play the move e6 and create
some havoc around the black king very
intriguing situation developing in this
one and only five minutes and 45 seconds
for mvl and seven minutes for nepo this
is definitely a game that we have to
keep our eye on
in the future knight b5 and the board
yeah i think your default setting here
is taking on c1 playing rook c8 because
you do want to offload some pieces i
would assume from the board you don't
really
and i'm not going to exchange that i'm
going to go root to d1 d1 or somewhere
or maybe even e1 in some cases because
e5 e6 is going to be one very very
important part of the equation he's
going for it from your lips to
the chess board itself rook takes c1
would take c1 rook c8 on the board and
you were saying christian
keep the pieces keep the pieces on now
we're keeping the pieces the question is
whether we choose this square or even
because i i like the idea of sort of
hinting at the five or six somewhere i
like rookie one yes you prefer rook
edgar one now the question is do i have
queen to b4 and just knock queen i like
this
i don't think it's that great no i think
i think the point here is like we can
play rook c5
and if you go 94 we're in time to play
bishop c8
and you know this looks very
aesthetically pleasing from from the
white side but there's only three pieces
left on the board and we've controlled
the 5v6 brake right with the bishop on
c8 and uh you know black is still a pop
and what if i go knight d6
i can still go bishop c8 i think right
it feels like i should have some sort of
tricks
but i don't see that yeah it's not
immediately obvious like queen of six
and the rookie one as you say keep
keeping the pieces but this rook c5
definitely the most annoying move uh in
the position for white to phase
i think so yeah i think he's going for
it i think so yeah because the bishop
needs to be on c8 like if you allow e6
in a good like if if e6 lands
effectively yeah very often just wins
the game which is why the bishop on b7
needs to be included in the uh in the
defense in some way
you can even maybe make an argument for
g494 bishop d5
but no i think i think roxy five is very
logical and now there is this trick but
i don't think it's made i think it's
just a perpetual we can play 96 queen c8
oh sorry bishop c
and bishop queen of six check
and by the way guys it seems like ali
reza is fully taking over the initiative
in his match against icarus i assume you
wanted to play
trade of queens but this is just giving
black everything he ever wants a better
endgame rook invading via b1 creating a
lot of threats you have to defend the
rook on f1 with the passive king on e2
and now i have so many options in which
i can continue this one
probably relate it with the move f7 f5
in the future and try at some point yeah
at some point you could you can be
slightly more
restrained and play g7 f6 king of seven
king e6 but that allows h4 h5 so you you
do have to actually king g7
that would be awkward yeah so anything
could be said for f5 absolutely yeah
it's it's a very very serious option
because after all there's this pin that
is not going anywhere and
you know we get an e4 uh game could be
over
right away
uh sorry you're you're about to question
you're about to i was also considering
the idea of blocking the weakness on my
on a3 with the move a5 a4
also very nice just yeah that's that's a
very good strategic idea as well and i i
don't want to point out that you know
for
perhaps at first glance you look at this
position you think you know there's only
one side on the on the board here who
has a protected passer and it's white
why is white in so much trouble i think
it's mainly just the activity of the
pieces so the bishop on c1 is kind of
horrible the rakon b1 is much more
active than the rook on f1
a3 is constantly hanging and if as we
keep on mentioning if the the pawns in
the center start rolling if you get f5
and d4 in and white hasn't done anything
yet
the game probably just ends and by the
way i just picked at the engine after f5
the best way for white continue is to
actually give up yeah i was i was
wondering about that yeah gfgf just take
and take on f5 and take on e5 and hope
that you will be able to simplify this
position all the way to the last part
thank you for that because
at the time i that i was suggesting if i
just didn't see a move yeah i like that
conclusion here without without knowing
what the engine says it's just
everything else just looks so horrible
that exactly you just come to the
conclusion that you might have to go all
in immediately yeah once again a
psychologically difficult decision to
make though absolutely
it's not easy but then again hikaru is
extremely extremely good at practical
practical chess and he knows that sort
of changing the character of the game
completely uh right now
is maybe his best shoulder take on e5
you still have two pawns left on the
board for black and that might be a
problem
if that pawn from the a file would be on
the h file
and the potential of exchanging the
rooks exchange the d pawn and have the
bat pawn and that's going to be a draw
but with the pawn on the a file that's a
good pawn any end game is gfgf played
another kind of an indication that he's
ready to play rook f5 big moment right
now here it is
let's see if he's going to take on f5
also is there anything to be said about
but the problem i see with this piece
sacrifice is at the end of the day no
he's not going without reaching for but
where is he going it looked like he was
reaching first bishop where was the
position
i think king should take three maybe
five no bishops he'll play three wins on
the spot right right king d2 bishop a3
so which play three ends whoa
ah maybe he thinks the ball ending is
playable but it shouldn't be right
really with two eight wait a minute well
he also has he also has a uh bridesmaids
right c pawn is that so he's going for
his goal for this
wait but how do you get into uh the end
game we should play three kingshito
rookie
oh yeah you can actually wait forever
pretty much like yeah h4 f4 i i will
take when i'm actually already winning
completely at some point i will go e4
well yeah like i think e4 might be
problematic
so h just over i think he just might
have missed bishop takes a3 this is
incredible
also i suspect the pawn ending is lost
but nobody wants to check like i suspect
if we take on c1 twice and play five i
think we win
but
i will check it for you um
no it's actually winning for white
you were so close on this one peter yeah
that's very very bizarre to me
five king of seven so a5
the king is actually uh
and the bird seat here uh looking both
east and west
nice wow so
this is a big question king to c2 rook
to a1 and what if i start going c5
uh sorry again christian
a1 yeah rk1 because yeah as with
otherwise bishop a3 on the uh board uh
sorry
by the way king to c2 is not yet on the
board hikaru seems to be thinking that
c5 is also an option
what bishop takes if oh then
then takes f5
so c5 might be an option
uh
but imagine having to calculate all
these races with one minute on the clock
not easy and he's reaching and yeah
he's got c5
uh
i'm i i
so very much want to win some kind of
upon ending here but that looks like i
shouldn't
shouldn't be attempting to do that
huh
uh
can we see this crazy move f4 for just a
second
f4
whoa whoa whoa what is it i mean it's
four this is c6 she sees me six and then
we go after it
yeah and by the way
linear and
sam will yeah that game will end in a
draw there i think they may be checking
if it's a threefold already but the
position is very very over
like it's they've been shuffling a very
cool position for a while now okay a
draw on that one and back to our game of
vikarra for just a moment uh c5
this is a huge moment uh do you see a
better move than f4 peter king f7 maybe
yeah i was i was wondering about kf7 uh
i also think that we are significantly
better if we just take on c5 and go
bishop d6 like we we're still a pawn up
the bishop on c1 is still extremely
horrible so
we we don't actually need to commit to
an all-or-nothing kind of race a kind of
an all-in all-in push if we if we want
to
just not have to calculate very much
this is the way not to calculate very
much
uh but king of seven if king of seven is
playable i'm very much in favor of
playing king of seven rook five king e6
rook f1 and then just taking on c5 i
think it's just a very much improved
version of the position i was trying to
get anyway king of seven rook five king
e6 it has to go back to f1 i don't think
this is the pawn ending i was once again
very interested like with our king so so
uh
well
yeah can we now take on c1 twice go five
a5 a4 a3 and then create a d-passer but
i assume it's still not very good but
just take on c5 here
yeah i mean clearly it's uh
black and finally the move that
my eye was drawn to uh which was this
one yeah well then king si tu i think
this is the issue and once again it very
much depends on the spawn ending right
because right we're still not winning on
the king side and white might still
actually be faster shockingly even
though we want a full tempo also yeah
okay yeah
would be painful agreed agreed that is a
painful thing to miss
okay so here it is bishop c5 i think you
eventually defaulted default to some
kind of a version of bishop takes c5 i
think agreed
and in the uh remaining f7 just feels
like the much more natural approach uh
when you see it when we left it jeffrey
versus fabi we really didn't like
jeffrey jeffrey is still much better but
he's not winning because he um
well that position we were discussing
realm of 20 he chose bishop before
allowing a5 guys check the time check
the time situation right now between
between them
and what is it 31 seconds for fabiano
four minutes and 45 seconds for
uh jeffrey pretty one-sided there on the
clock that tells you a lot
yeah and uh it's been like this for a
while black really has no way of
improving but uh everything seems to be
protected for now which is why you know
jeffrey is not really making
any kind of significant progress like if
this bishop finds a way to you know get
a dark square issue like if you get it
over to c3
and you haven't lost the c4 pawn yet and
you're here you're probably sorry you're
probably just winning you're probably
winning right but the the trick here is
to organize it in such a way like php3 i
think pretty much always gets replied to
with knight a5 so you have to
he's gone bishop c5 i like that yeah so
knight a5 he will give a check from
rugby five maybe actually ah he's clever
he he wants to preserve the option of
playing rugby five this is sorry i think
what he's trying to do is if you go rook
to c7 by the way
98 players knight d8 on the ball
this is actually still horrible bishop
before check we win the b7 pawn was
check you're absolutely right this is
still
like it's just this might be over yeah
yeah yeah i agree but i think starting
with bishop depot check is probably
cleaner
wow as well yeah this is this is going
to be very very torturous for for
fabinho oh boy
and again it was so surprising to see uh
after a
mere
one and a half dozen moves fabi being
2.0 down according to the computer
very very very surprising and less time
and finally
once again what has
what happened with the mvl game
it has simplified yeah simplified white
still has some pressure i would assume
but when we left should we do that
rook c5 they they followed everything we
did
except uh
jan threw in a very important b4
yes
down to as you can see on your screen uh
10 seconds against three minutes here
yeah he's trying to figure out if he can
play g5 d4 and he
in the end went with the answer no
well knight e8 to f6 check is this it's
but it's not a mate it's a bundle it's a
bunch of checks but it's not made right
uh it's not you know
we stay on just g7 h6 and we kind of and
i go g4 yeah i think this is why he's
trying to drive the king to g3 like he
will king king of two he'll go ruxin to
check but then don't i have ideas of
king f4 king g5
yeah and this is once again this is why
king age to happen
one and now his idea is rookie one which
is
uh yeah he's trying to provoke a three
or four after which i'm assuming the
king on h6 is actually kind of
completely safe
right because then i no longer get in g4
yeah now i think we can just go d5 d4
and 98 is a perpetual but i don't think
it wins so you were saying that
that in case of king
f2 yeah i think his plan was to go roxy
to check
i see king g3 yeah and once the king is
on g3 i think i can go d4 knight to
d3 and
without the inclusion of g4 g5 at the
end there you do have checks but i don't
think you can give you can give may to
that king on g7h6 remarkable all right
let's let's catch up on what the players
actually have played okay so this entire
line that we were discussing did happen
in the foggy game
yeah but let's let's watch this for a
bit because is there is there anything
here for
um
he feels like bishop five is even
playable because yeah the king is
surprisingly safe on those squares
without without g4 g5 to
support the attack it's like i've been
hardwired for these uh patterns here i
can't escape the
the the belief that black
king is dead dead dead but not but it's
not yeah it's not it's uh
white obviously risks absolutely nothing
but it doesn't feel like there's any way
to make progress and all of them are
heating up but i have to say hikaru
versus fuja that's a big one okay
is breaking through right now
whoa virgin has collected a lot of
material somehow he did after the c5
move he captured
he did what we expected with uh
and just
as a security is such a cute move there
may have been missed by by hikaro just
using a tempo here with the intermediate
rook takes d3 if you take on a3 so that
wins the very important d3 pawn a very
nice tempo when indeed and the times
38 seconds for hikaru two minutes for
fusion
[Music]
okay but rook to e6 is coming right yep
so you have rook h3 for that rook to h3
seems to be the right way followed by d3
followed by d3 check and i assume this
just is faster
let's look at that rook two h3 is
awesome yeah rook a6 does look like it's
the only tri if you don't attack these
these pawns immediately you will never
have any counter play so i think it has
to be played maybe there is some
argument for pushing the king you know
but you don't need it you're making the
king better and now i think you have to
play king of two and try to like king g2
is a threat now it tries weirdly
but
whoa bishop c5 check
and yeah after that
takes h4 oh my goodness no but then i
have
five yeah because there's bishop d4 at
the end incredible so you cannot take he
goes rook g6 checks so he decided that
the king is worst place on g7 than it is
on g8 which is interesting i considered
it briefly but i couldn't really work
out why that would be okay
yeah because you can't really cross the
e file
but you can play king of seven king g7
and then he'll play he'll play rookie
six then and i guess he feels that
having the bishop f6
uh
idea in reserve is going to be useful
for him
i don't know if it will be because it
always gets like bishops check king of
seven is just going to be
harder to deal with if anything exactly
a rook to e6 rookie six i mean
but the bigger issue is still like how
do you protect e5 without that
trick with d3 king of two he's gone king
f2 instantly he's going to have two
without rookie six this is very
confusing by the way rookie six he also
had the idea of bishop b2
ah yeah rookie six bishop okay so what
is the trick after bishop to e7
yeah i'm i'm so confused by king of two
what's uh what's the trick after bishop
membership takes g5 yeah why are we
allowing rook to e3 and then rookie
three
why are we allowing yeah this is very
very confusing to me
i don't think there is a trick yeah
ooh it always feels like hikaru has
something in the back yeah but obviously
this is just a mistake bishop e7 is just
winning and hey karo shaking his head
like what the heck am i thinking
yeah i think he just missed it bishop
yeah i think he's just missed bishop e7
and that's those positions those
positions never hold you know like it's
just yeah
he will play rookie six that's a
technical win and actually
he'd immediate resignation wow as
farouja surges into the lead with
back-to-back victories
and back-to-back defeats for hikaru yeah
this is maybe even even more of a
defending champion
yes yeah currently on zero out of four
it's not even zero out of two it's you
know zero out of four considering the
scoring system is zero out of four yeah
that's not a good thing yeah we'll take
a draw here because yeah the pawn is now
on g2 which is really making it
progressive
progressively difficult to
to you know generate threats or even
pretend to generate so i think we should
go to fabiano's game yeah exactly
where again we're expecting a draw in
the game between
and fabi is defending upon down bishops
of opposite colors two could be two
pawns now two pawns down bless you
yeah sorry about that yeah the h5 pawn
will uh will will fall as well i like
rugby six check i like driving
driving the blockers away from my five
squares and so on now we can take on h5
he's gone king d7
so if you take on h5 so i have looked to
d3 yeah bishop would be three yeah okay
yeah that's it uh
so you're sure you're drawing actually
i'm not sure
pretty sure i'm losing that yeah yeah
that can guess the g7 that might be
problematic yeah yeah i think it should
take an h5 i mean he will play rook d3
and if jeffrey plays bishop b2 he will
have to play something like i don't know
rook f3 or g3 tried to
cut off
yeah rook g3 but it shouldn't hold
generally speaking those types of
positions shouldn't hold no
if you don't have
uh believe uh they've been talking about
a repetition and a draw
is it done
well mvl on the back foot there uh
and we all have to defend yeah i'm not
sure what exactly jan is so unhappy
about it didn't really
at our cursory glance it didn't really
seem like he by the way guys five
seconds for jeffrey
what yeah but it's a position where it's
not
five seconds though that's critical
rook to beef i mean with the king cut
like that what if i just simply approach
you with a kink in 360. yeah i'm very
surprised by rook before i don't know
what rook b4 is about i would have been
blinking issues
in h5
can you see rook g4 that was actually
blundering one of our extra pawns which
is why he didn't play it rook to b5 but
yeah i don't know i don't know that
seems
this does
improve his case yeah
no this feels like uh with the rook on
g3 most especially that uh fabi's
drawing chances went significantly
so you don't have five ships a five
check exists right now which i think is
what jeffrey was very much counting on
and that rook ending i think is winning
if it happens right f5 which by five
rookie five but yeah jeffrey says i
don't need to calculate i can play
slowly for now
by the way f5 check bishop on b2 is
hanging right right that's but i i i
haven't before in the end yeah i have a
foreign but yeah it's irrelevant we're
not there he's gained some time
uh
and now he has to decide on something
okay so that and i have a feeling i have
a feeling five is good but in in
practical terms but uh
it's maybe not such an easy decision to
make because yeah it's okay there it is
there it comes and i think has to take
because if you leave it if you leave it
alive if you allow it to reach f6
your drawing chances diminish
significantly so you have to go for some
version of that rook ending okay king d7
by the way you weren't here for the
american cup but in in the first round
between these two fabi won the match by
the fact he was lost
he had a losing position and jeffrey
with one second on this clock hit his
clock and his clock expired
uh fabi went on to win the american cup
but had he lost that game uh
he would have been relegated
uh down
so
these two breaks yeah bishop b3 it was a
bad break bishop b3
okay by the way don't hang the bishop on
b2 yeah that would be that would be
unnecessary but there's a you should
have seven check isn't there yes but
what does it do oh my god
yeah we're looking at h7
ah so actually helps me
sorry he agreed uh all around
honestly i'm a little bit surprised he
played f6 so
five seconds for fabi he has to make a
move king to e6 okay rookie five check
though why are we no this i don't like
at all yeah i don't i don't like the
idea of allowing
the king to be further cut off rookie
seven is looking very strong now and not
only that but it's a it's a move that
you you you play you gain time the
probably the rookie seven i think i
might have some bishop to the rook g5 oh
five is also good yeah all of these
things are strong but yeah i thought we
should be one king king h6 there i
thought that was very strong i didn't
think we had to worry about much
yeah rook g4 bishop e5 yeah yeah i don't
i don't like allowing the king back to
e6 which is like i thought the rook just
belonged on e7
that is not to say that this is not a
winning position it probably is just
playing g6 now exactly yeah like this is
a kind of a
bishop to c3 okay right my goodness king
g6 how could you how could you resist
playing king james yeah
logical there
so
so nice
so black needs to keep touch with the
bishop on c3 contact with the bishop one
c3 rook to d3 or to c2 it feels like
rook c2 to be able to take on f6 if uh
i think he's sensing or at least he's
kind of trying to bluff king six didn't
play but this is just bad
i'm surprised by this
king g6
is a huge threat right now this is over
f7 f7 is also big
five seconds for fabiano to make a move
four three rook of two back but now we
can even play like h5 yeah we don't need
like nothing is even hanging everything
is over no this is a dream yeah this
construction is just too solid like rook
f3 we can play bishop d4 or bhp5 yeah
like just keep the box
as safe as well i was about to say
bishop e5 everybody's protecting
everybody
yeah the whole
yeah
the whole construction continues moving
forward i just got bishop b2 and now i
guess this is just a game another uh
yeah just just gaining some time yeah
he wants to he wants to play hp5 with
the tempo this is kind of
uh you know nice
nice little sadistic touch there by
jeffrey by jeffrey i just
in a completely winning position being
you know maximizing everything you know
proper mean maxing effort here by
by jeffrey
and now bhp five and we've we've gotten
exactly where we wanted to get to
precisely but we've gained all the time
as well exactly yeah
and
as you say
just
keeps
going up the board yeah it's just uh
push him
not a great situation right now for you
he'll give a check
you can't really shift any of this and
eventually the bishop will go somewhere
rookie five check will happen and you
just
i think he's right also h7 currently h7
is a problem yeah h7 currently h3 f7 and
you resign
no this is just a resignation time right
now
yeah rupert b3 okay i have seven if
seven would be seven which is kind of
queued by five he continues finding
these
these little you know snippets of uh of
chances but yeah it shouldn't
against 20 seconds though
by the way bishop to c7 now
yeah and rookie five five seven yeah
yeah this is nice they should make it
nicely nicely done by jeffrey uh nicely
done some nice tactics by jeffrey by the
way that would mean that fabi and hikaru
both fall to 0 out of 4. no no
sorry
so he's one out of four still not very
encouraging
excuse me not really no he did play the
lowest rated players in this event
shanklin and jeffrey
yeah now rookie five check king d7 f7
ends the game yeah just just kind of
completely or rookie seven check and
then f7
there's not even room g3 check we've
just taken away all the squares you're
just going
this size yeah
oh my goodness that's it
yeah nicely converted by jeffrey well
done
wow
wow
so hikaru
hikaru
[Music]
once again two wins out of the five
games forty percent
absolutely i don't think anyone is on
two out of two but
hikaru
zero out of two a zero out of four
depending on how you want to right you
know whether you want to really rub it
in alireza wins his first two games
right so he's four
yeah it's fine
yeah that's what i meant
well that's well for my predictions guys
whoa uh
whoa uh
we're flanking you you're not hungry
we're flanking you guys
yeah well you're solid i'm still okay
with mine yeah it's just you know his
skill has been he's been very solid so
far and so uh anastasia and i are like
uh
didn't see that one coming it's uh it's
a long wait and let's take a look at all
the standings uh peter i
like to say you're solid you're solid
with uh and there you have it
winning both games today so far uh
linear on plus uh plus one with one
minute and one draw jeffrey on plus one
with one minute one draw as well then a
bunch of people on 50 with two draws
and then fabian shah
on minus one and hikaru starting with a
short costling so far
and with round three coming our way are
we going to show our pairings for round
three or are we just going to
potentially
we can tell the the good people the
pairings even if we don't show them and
the parents four round three there they
are well show them yes uh uh so five he
plays white against uh jan uh dominguez
uh shong is our battle of two players
tied for second yeah alireza who isn't
clearly plays white against sam shanklin
so
potentially an opportunity for him to go
uh through three and uh three and zero
today uh lev is white against hikaru uh
and mbl is white against shah
wonderful and round three will be coming
up very shortly we will be back
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
and here are the standings as you can
see alireza leading there on four out of
four
and uh dominguez and jeffy shong
following up on three out of four there
jan levan maxim and assam all of 50
percent two draws as the round three our
final round of the day
underway and there you see a picture of
the playing hall uh the player is hard
at work i've got the game between mvl
and shaq on my screen
open
rui lopez that
falls in and out of fashion but
currently very much in currently a lot
of the top players are playing it with
the black pieces although we're not
going to see uh
arguably the most topical line of the
open spanish the one with the sacrifice
on f2 right because the bishop from f8
got developed to e7 and not c5
so this will be uh this will be a
slightly more restrained kind of an open
now uh here um a kind of a slightly
quirky move order with knight c3 i don't
think being the
uh i think 9b2 remains sort of more
fashionable than other than c3
but we shall see and obviously
plenty of stuff going on elsewhere as
well exactly now peter is an e4 player
you know you've had to put in a fair
amount of time on the open spanish and
yet when nobody ever plays it against
you you feel like did you waste all
not exactly and uh
these days
i think
currently you know now is the time to
actually study it properly because as i
mentioned like chakriar has uh played it
very very seriously
bobby himself uh played a bunch of a
bunch of the open spaces being in madrid
there's there's a lot of very very
strong players who made it this she had
it as his repertoire yeah against fish
specifically i i had a bunch of very
interesting uh
battles in uh in the open spanish over
the years but that's dating back to like
late 90s so long long time ago right uh
so yeah we'll see what happens here uh
we also have on other boards we have
[Music]
heavily theoretical
between uh jeffrey linear and jeffrey
with uh linear
uh arguably sort of loki one of the uh
last remaining proponents of fighting
the main lines of the especially of i
think people have
kind of given it up well i mean the the
the russolima is just way way more
popular these days than the
i feel that the mainline session goes
but yeah uh linear is still
insisting yeah team team 3d4 here okay
and uh
we also have an
uh an auntie berlin in the game between
ferruga and uh shankland here as you can
see
kind of a quiet uh quiet game in
progress so far with g3 bishop c5 bishop
c6
um a line that has always been kind of
bubbling uh
i want to say bubbling under the surface
but that's actually unfair because i
think it's it's very much the central
yeah the central
uh the central the you know
battleground of uh of uh white trying to
get somewhere against this opening the
berlin and then we'll go to now here's
lavonne
playing against hikaru nakamura who's
actually lost his first two games
and do you think to yourself as lavon oh
my goodness this is wonderful the target
is the number one seed i've got to beat
him like everybody else is beating him i
mean livon i think has a good score
against hikaru and they've had some you
know very published very well publicized
huge
huge clashes over the years and uh
but
you you completely disregard the the the
fact that hikaru has no point so far
like we it's still hikaru you know you
still you still know you're playing one
of the absolute best rapid and blitz
players in the world and like i don't
think
i don't think it
is really gets factored into your
decision making very much
not uh
not not one of those blood in the water
i've got to go after him types wait i
mean he's white in a tournament where
you know with every white europe
in particular this being the one is a
very ambitious player the one is yes it
doesn't really play
you know not to try right it's very rare
that you see him not try with the white
pieces but
yeah i don't think hikaru's score will
affect future feature largely in his
decision making now a very strategic uh
maneuvering battle going on as the fight
over these uh central square uh d4 and
white's desire uh to get in the move f2
f4 probably something like that well
we'll keep an eye on that one and
finally
the last game yeah move 17 and they both
are above their starting times
people people what have we got here what
people appear to like working on chess i
don't quite understand okay okay and
nimzo indian
this is extremely topical this this kind
of weird move order has become very very
topical recently and it's actually very
reminiscent of uh the type of position
that fabiano played against sam savion i
think in the american cup it's exactly
what he's doing
this might explain why
e4 and try to get d5 going try to break
through in the center yeah wasn't that
something with rook b2 and f4 or even f4
yeah and rick that was that was a wild
donny brook going on uh
rook knight
some immediate questions you have to
three
rook d2 borderline only move here
right yeah and and now uh you would like
to play knight c4 but rook g3 actually
uh
i'm not sure rookie three queen a1 is
still playable for black
this is a very good game before he's on
the board yeah unless he fall played i
wonder if the idea is maybe to take on
c4 and if you take with the bishop or
rook i will play bishop b2 and d4 d5
will be
so if you take with the bishop yeah
bishop two but we have queen b3
very very importantly we have queen b3
here as black meaning that d4 d5 is
maybe still playable but if the queens
come over much less scared about it
exactly
unless there is some crazy one i'm
playing grenade one here and hoping that
d5 like 98 i'll just put knight e8
rookie 3 h4 d5 knight f5 mate on mate on
the move 25 or something alright
this is the plan here that's the script
yeah i like it it's just the plan uh
sure but this is all happening very very
quickly nice
the case that i can chase your queen so
bishop takes c4 bishop to b2 queen b3
queen a1 queen a2
let's continue so i missed completely
yeah this is probably the idea because i
i really just like everything else there
which which line so bishop takes c4
bishop b2 queen to b3 and i continue
chasing the queen queen to a one queen
to a2
yeah i know it looks funny i it
shouldn't work but can you avoid the
queen trade well the problem is is maybe
i can
90 80 well i'm taking on g7 all right
bishop takes defense is that enough or
even maybe king g7 or knight
knight
yeah i mean how bad is this
i don't think it's that bad i think it's
probably playable yeah eg5 knight on g7
covers a lot of important squares so the
knight on g3 doesn't jump i was about to
say the knight on g7 is badly placed but
it's kind of both right yeah
it does protect that fight i agree but
it's horribly plays but it's also
controlling the knight on g3 doing a
very good job of controlling the legend
right so what if you try to avoid the
queen trade not queen takes a 2 buck
queen c1
here
sure why not so after queen 282 now my
way to queen to c1
i'm still threatening maybe d5 actually
now rook to c2 maybe is the biggest
yeah weird this is true by the way we do
have bishop c4
i mean qb3 is the only legal move in the
position we're actually getting all of
this maybe yeah queen b actually i'm
lying about bishop queen b3 being the
only move we can play queen b we can
play bishop b3 instead of queen b3
but by the way nepo is still not
spending absolutely any time up at this
point and he has played queen v3 by the
way so he must know something
he must have deeply analyzed this
position
so queen a1 looks very very attractive
you're setting up ideas no you you have
to play queen i i mean queen a2 is
is on the board yeah
and do they still do both players still
have more time
fabiano down to his last uh well
his last 25 minutes 23 minutes
he spent
two minutes i mean you can maybe make an
argument for playing 98 first and if you
go rookie three then i maybe go queen a2
anyway but it's weird i don't like to
give the white queen more squares
sorry uh once again peter in this
position like if you go if you go knight
eight here i go three yeah and then go
queen a2 then okay i have more squares i
have queen e1 for instance which wasn't
available earlier and i'm pretty sure
i'm not yeah i'm pretty sure i'm not
happy about this with black because
exactly why have i done this to myself
right but also i have a feeling that if
you do go knight e8 maybe i can just
simply go d5 with that and then my
argument was i can postpone it for one
move and go queen 82 then
right right uh
but then i go queen d1 and queen g4 oh
yeah yeah yeah that's the queen now
without the knight on f6 yeah that as
well
yeah it feels like queen a2 might
actually be required and has been played
by the way um has been played
not waiting for d5
you have to do it now niceties you have
to do it now
yeah but it
there's something really amusing about
hunting down white screen i will force
you to trade we cannot
we we we cannot play chess uh with
queens on the board uh by the way uh
alejandro is proposing that you should
play the move queen c1 christian was
also yeah very much in fact and uh
playing for the advantage with uh the
queens on the board it's funny because
bishop to b3 actually you're attacking
my queen but your queen gets bishop c3
this is very amusing like the entire
thing is kind of extremely amusing
true true so we think queen c1 might be
the best uh
right right what if i go bishop d5
bishop to d5 sure
let's try this one do you go queen to d1
yeah now we go queen d1 i think
what and i don't have queen to b3 yeah
because you
you no longer have the queen b3 idea
because the bishop is hanging we should
be three queen of three i think or queen
e2 maybe i don't want to allow rooks now
you're starting to gain some traction
yeah yeah yeah
and again d5 is the uh if g5 lands this
is not going to be over very fun
amusing wow um
now my question to you guys is was this
just simply a bluff by nepo
allowing this whole variation because
he's playing it so fast now if you don't
play the move queen to c1 and by the way
it wasn't played queen takes a2 is on
the board
that just gives black an easy play right
yeah this is fine yeah white is not
going to be worse but white is not going
to define knight eight simply like orbit
should be three or whatever right now
you don't have to worry you're not
winning this one well bishop to b3 maybe
bishop takes f6 and knight to each other
might want to be
you even this you're probably still okay
but yeah
it does look like an interesting kind of
a semi-blow i don't know if it's
entirely a bluff but a kind of an
interesting semi bluff there by jan
because
yeah quincy one is not an easy like if
you don't know
and your opponent is on 25
25 10 by move 23 or something like you
probably
suspect that something is not quite
right with it feels like a bluff
he did play knight eight by the way
yeah if you don't play if you don't play
bishop takes g7 you have absolutely
nothing whatsoever you might actually
have to start fighting for equality okay
once again uh shall we peter just take a
quick look because we have different
ideas it's not even the only move right
after bishop g7 there are other options
and
yeah i just i was just saying because uh
first before for me the contrast between
these two nights i didn't know if i was
doing uh
yeah i don't know roxy three
and
96
i don't think i don't think i'm
struggling here with the 2k3 yeah two
pawns on the queen side yeah as long as
a lot of stuff gets traded on d4 i don't
get mated you're why am i why am i
you're not here you're not but also
after bishop g7 just to point out that
please if if we want to avoid this we
can go bishop 7 bishop d5
and yes maybe we will be ever so
slightly worse but i don't think it's
much anyway
again it doesn't feel like eg597 now is
completely safe for black and if you go
like b5 here i'll go i don't know bishop
c4 or bishop b3 or somewhere there
should be three problems right i mean
how bad can this be no uh yeah again if
uh
if there's no checkmates uh no knight
h5s no rook to g3 ideas then black as
well i think i think we control enough
squares in the center here to be quite
safe but to answer your question
christian i don't think that this was a
bluff i mean the fact that
he uh nepo was playing so quickly the
whole line with queen b3 and queen a2 i
mean i don't know yesterday it's plus
1.6 according to my engine after queen
c1 so that's a significant point yeah
but on that topic i wanted to say that
you know this is specifically nepal
right this is somebody who we have seen
over the years yeah
just blitz out stuff because he felt
like blitzing some stuff out you know
that's
the way to go yeah i mean just yeah
your engine says queen c1 quincy one and
that one
edge to white yes yeah no i mean it's uh
dang peter it really did feel like it's
uh
there's some some light bluffing but
queen c1 is the only move by the way
right after d after take on a2 and d5
knight to e8 this is just immediate
equality what we have actually in the
inequality yes okay uh shall we turn to
our tournament leader uh ali reza as
he is uh two and oh and who is he
playing against samsung
when we left it we were in this kind of
topical uh
line of the berlin
and it's interesting because alireza i
think has been uh
but obviously like there's move order
questions here which i don't feel
qualified to speak of but
one reasonably fashionable uh set up for
white in these types of structures
recently has been the idea of playing
bishop g5
uh while the pawn is still on f7 let's
say we go back to i don't know move nine
yeah do something around here yeah like
hdi7 we go bishop g5 f6 bishop h4 we put
it on g3 okay and then we go for the
plan of c3 and d4 with the bishop on g3
very much useful in supporting this push
in the center and i think alireza
himself has been very much at the
forefront of trying this but he's doing
something else altogether today with the
bishop still very much on c1 and he's
playing against uh what we americans
really think is a great opening
theoretician once again shankland uh sam
works very very hard on his openings and
he is sam's
hanging right there uh with uh ali reza
in terms of meeting him yeah g6 is an
interesting kind of a move because it
feels like you're softening your
structure and it doesn't feel
immediately obvious but he was clearly
concerned about the edgy of g5
driving the bishop away from e6 and then
landing the knight on the five in some
fashion maybe not immediately but maybe
even immediately honestly like the
knight of five here queen g8 and then
this kind of thing yeah exactly yeah so
g6 takes away the f5 square from the
knight on e3 and then he will consider i
assume with the pawn on a5 we are rarely
inside let's go a6 right yeah a6 b6 and
d5 anyway or something yeah
a6 b6 d5 makes sense we take knight g5
queen f7 i guess right yep
i don't know how good this is like it
doesn't feel horrible for black at all
like c4
we castle short bishop b3 we make some
move
i'm just a little bit worried that i may
be forced to go
long and
am i walking into i'm not uh i don't i
don't hate it honestly and yeah yeah
sorry casper playable to me we can also
take on g5 something about that pawn i
understand yeah but i was like i will
mention that i could take maybe take on
d5
instead of castling just previous move
force you to go e to hd5 and then maybe
i will consider playing g6 g5 in this
position and asking you how sure you are
yeah you actually you know that that
thing doesn't die there on h6 exactly
exactly
all right
cool
so a6 is on the board b6 probably is
going to be an immediate i don't think i
don't think you'll do anything else
basics is unborn now what if i just
simply go c4 into e or c yeah yeah
i was looking at c4 in all of these
positions just trying to get d5 and then
take with the c pawn because we don't
really want to take the e pawn if we can
help it right
okay that would be the tree
just take with the c pawn put a lot of
things and again
if i just fall for your nefarious
ideas yeah we
we're just arguing that we're slightly
better here like you can see a nice b3
or quincy two first and then we just do
something like it's just
it's going to be difficult for black to
generate too much counter play and maybe
queen c6 is an idea
it's slow we're not winning but
c6
yeah rook s8 followed by c6 might be a
very serious idea yeah for sure it
doesn't feel like
you know black has done you know and
unrecoverable things also offered
another just kind of flexible plan maybe
queen e2 muscle's short i guess yeah
maybe one
yeah just build it up slowly do you go
bishop f7 and now maybe
say that you are threatening take on d4
yeah
i mean these are all very kind of
intricate positions which are i think
difficult to play and difficult to judge
and perhaps even
instead of c4 by the way
knight to c4 c4 yes yes c4 definitely on
the board that's a serious question
asked by alireza
an immediate question
[Music]
because you do have the option of taking
on d4 and getting the knight to e5
but then f4 is coming now yeah it's
might be a bit too much exactly feels
feels very risky exactly exactly one way
to maybe keep things reasonably closed
would be to play c6 c5 here
wow i mean yeah it's it's a move it's a
move it's a move because
i understand it's kind of ugly g5 let's
say we go maybe we even go fe-5 but just
let's go full no full ugly is bad
because 95
yeah let's go g5 95
let's go full ugly
what is not full ugly sorry g5 knight e5
g5 knight takes e5 yeah like not
actually might take c5 but then i
continue taking right yeah you take i
take with the bishop or 95 first as well
and that if i first also kind of annoys
me a great deal right but maybe here i
can take on f3
you take with the queen i can take on d5
and claim i'm not doing so poorly
because yeah i mean it's kind of
horrible aesthetically but there's only
one open file and i might be able to
trade everything along it right it's my
you know my goal here yes yeah i'm not
arguing i've equalized or anything
i will make a draw right now those two
things are not the same
i will make a change i i i hear you loud
and clear the
the
the presence of the a6 pawn how yeah
meaningful or yeah i'm i'm not enjoying
even suggesting those things like this
is this is very much against money kind
of
interesting that sam again just louded
him as this great theoretician not kind
of seizing uh
the defensive position by the way let me
just jump back to lavonne and he's very
interesting this is very interesting
because uh
it was a big maneuvering yeah one did
play king h1 but then he didn't play a
four he played knight a4 bishop a7 and
queen e1 kind of hinting that the pawn
on a5 might be hanging do something
about this yeah bishop d7 for now
protects it by uh protecting the rook on
a8 so if you take on a5 bishop takes f2
and the rook is hanging on eight but
bishop d2 and now he is you know very
seriously saying to hikara would you
like to play b7 b6 with your bishop on
a7 and there is a story from
not my personal childhood but there is
like a
what was told to me it sounds like an
apocryphal story but it was told to me
like a true story and knowing the the
people
in the story it might very well be true
there was a kind of a fabled coach at
the uh pioneers palace in indian garden
the the central
you know seat of learning exactly
young students and there was a there was
a coach there named hovsky who was like
very very famous for being very strict
and kind of
the disciplinarian
serious about things and one of his
pupils
actually played b7 like probably c5 was
threatened or something bishop on a7 and
his position was bad
and he felt this position was bad enough
to justify playing b7 b6 to deal with
some immediate threats right and the
bishop obviously never came out right
exactly
and then hopski told him to go into uh
the uh stationery store
buy a 48 page
uh textbook facebook and write it a
thousand times bishop a7 b6 bishop a7 b6
like until until you finish the textbook
you're not getting up
and uh
that probably taught him not to do that
again but i i don't know if he may have
done something to his love for the game
as well but i don't think there was a
concern i i would assume that wasn't the
major concern at the time at this point
i mean yeah oh oh but as a trainer i
mean
that
that that must pain you to see your
people playing a movie like seven views
it's not great
on some level i understand the the
compiled way it's it's also quite
clearly you know abusive behavior we
don't condone right but you you also
understand why you would be tempted to
perhaps drive the lesson home firmly
don't do this to your bishops exactly
well in the meantime is fabi slightly
worse yes
uh what yes
just a moment uh we just left the game
and now i have to
where did you go but just before we go
to that one check this out so after c4
he played the move c if he did play g5
he went full ugly now the problem is we
were looking at he takes d4 and we were
saying that you cannot play that move
e94 apparently is the best move in the
position
e takes d4 take and knight to e5 defend
upon c6 attack the pawn on c4 and after
f4 it seems like the variations after
knight takes c4 knight knight to c6
queen to d7 are still just simply fine
for black e takes d4 would have been the
best move right now after c5 d5 bishop
to f7 and then knight to e1 knight to d3
and at some point i'm going to break
with either b4 or f4 and that's just
going to give me a free attack
as white it just seems like white is
going to be able to develop its
initiative quite comfortably without
having to worry about any sort of f5 on
the king side from black so i really
like what firuja is doing right now we
might be seeing alireza gone three out
of three undefeated
in this tournament in day one that's a
huge lead because let's not forget every
single win in the rapid section counts
as two points
right
very much so and uh well well done by by
those you know smart people among us who
picked others
you have a feeling you must be feeling
very very proud of yourselves terrible
terrible c5
d5 i want to just ask you this question
peter so you sit there and you go okay
white's better but you know for me to
win this game as white
then i have to do something i'm not
really happy about it either i'm going
to play b4 or i'm going to play f4 and
then giving up squares for the pieces
yeah absolutely in either case the
bishop
roars to life yeah and so maybe i start
thinking that maybe the move d5 isn't so
attractive i was going to say that yeah
it's curious to me that the solution
here is actually to play d5 because it
feels that when you play c65 here with
black this is what you're hoping for
this is right you're assuming that after
d5 the position becomes
so completely closed down everywhere
that you will be able to sort of
maneuver yourself out of trouble and you
know you could maybe even make an
argument for
uh
queenside being safe enough to castle
into in some cases although queen a4c6
kind of will give me majority
no okay no no not castling
coincidentally okay
but by the way he took on e5 yeah and
and i think this is very very natural
from a human perspective
you want to
you know your opponent is underdeveloped
and you your instincts are telling you
you have to play forcibly you have to
play actively right now because it might
not be uh you know available later so
he's he took on c5 he took on c5 this is
not a movie the
the the the last move uh i would look at
personally yeah this is not something
we've considered seriously i mean it's
still going to be followed up by 95 in
some shape of form but i'm assuming i
take and then have it
oh sorry uh yeah it would be quincy too
to try to go yeah we start we will start
quincy too and okay but now you at least
give me an option of uh
changing completely right so rook to d1
before b5 is also semi-playable i don't
know it's it's a very complicated
position yeah
well
i've got the two bishops i'm not
immediately busted wait a minute wait
what's going on hold on sorry
do do something here after queen knight
takes c5 queen c2 c6 i thought b4 b5 is
critical but there is a number of
replies to that which seemed to be fine
for black to be honest yeah i i don't
know
dc5 is really you wasn't very i i was
not my radar at all i mean i was aware
the move existed but that was basically
the extent of my involvement with it
right i just wasn't people wasn't ever
planning to make that so perhaps after
taking on c5 let's go knight d5
the move that you guys initially won
sure and here it was queen of seven
let's see i i was more or less drawn to
the move queen f7 not immediately oops
excuse me not immediately no we're not
taking until we're forced to take this
and we have the knight on d5 yeah but e4
is hanging if you play quincy i
i will hit it with c76 and it will have
go you will have to go away exactly and
by the way we do have knight uh d5 on
the board yeah queen f7 played as
expected
it feels like you might have to play
rookie one because you
might but then rook g8 like we're still
getting the things that i think he
played it he played the rookie one yeah
rookie one maybe we played before here
and the question is can we play c7 c6
but do we also do we want to play 7-6
what's wrong with 97
wow
wow
wait but what if i take on c5 bishop
takes bishop takes and then i have an
option of taking on f6
yeah oh you want to play queen 6 bishop
g5
this might actually work you know maybe
96.6 bishop g5 rook g1 rook d1 even
yeah well
that's actually quite funny
i think it works no but you have queen
g7 right oh yeah yeah it doesn't work
okay blindness sorry i've g7 square just
completely disappeared off of my off of
my radar
wow okay let's not get too carried away
we were having fun there but i was
thinking that we were just playing
knight d7 yeah 97 is
i mean
four was not uh
frightening anybody
probably not bishop h6 exists but maybe
look at g5 yeah we have to look at g5
again yeah
okay why is it not frightening let's go
queen to a4 queen a4 castles okay let's
put the bishop on h6 just because i like
that bishop there
actually i'm not sure if i would like it
so much but you can decide later sure no
let's go queen c6 my b8 i think solves
that issue right might be a queen b7 c6
and don't i have some knight takes piece
i yeah i don't know
yeah i don't think you do i don't think
you do
no i don't have it
no
not too surprising uh
you you you were saying that fabi stood
worse yeah he's fighting fighting for
equality i assume he will
he will equalize and do course but yeah
it's it's not it's not easy it's not
easy really
what did he do wrong when we left it we
he didn't take on g7 i guess he didn't
like i think if you want to make sure
you're not worse here i think you take
on g7 i think bishop d4
kind of
just blithely assuming that you're not
going to be worse in the same game i
think it just looks like you're worse
the lenten g3 is
misplaced
and the knight from e8 is going to aim
for the c4 square very very very very
quickly i mean it's really not a
surprise that he's fighting for equality
here and by the way that's an open c
file for the opponent yeah 961 and i
very much like bishop b3 here uh saying
to fabi that like if you have to take i
mean i think fabi will now have to like
after bishop takes c2 i think he goes
like
i think he goes like bishop d2 or
something he tries stupid he tries to
[Music]
suggest that there is nothing stronger
here than knight takes e4 and then it is
a draw of course
but you're not forced to do it you can
play a5 here for instance like
i would like to take on e4 with the
bishop right yeah of course
with the threat as you said just about
to say a bishop takes e4 since there's
no bishop before
and bishop e3 will be met by knights
before and then b5 before be three
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i know i know
how the squares are numbered you know
okay so what if i go f5 here
i know
it looks terrible but what
you might have to yeah for sure
but then i go knight c4 anyway bishop c1
by the way we do have a5 and king f2 on
the board yeah after b5 i don't think i
mean king of two king f2 should take c4
we just won the uh before b3 is his plan
ah clever clever boy
uh
okay
so what happens if we go knight c4
anyway are we like
it feels another funny three probably
holds right something like p3
oh you don't know pleasure c1
maybe i can start with bishop b3
um how fast are you in this whole race
here peter i don't know
i mean the one one like three e3 is
gonna yeah a lot of fun right now
probably still makes the draw right yes
because the
the shake on before i have four ninety
nine two ninety two ninety six like i'm
i'm actually kind of still somewhat
interested with black right yes you are
yes you're interested yeah and like just
like how how miserable
it must be for fabi to have this
position that's what i'm thinking as
well i mean what a terrible outing in
day one
i mean
you might save this or you might not
like if you play knight b3 here
bishop d5 knight takes a5 that knight
never like i think i lost a game like
this to kramnik once
the knight just dominated because he
just plays as if this knight doesn't
exist like king is like h5 right now to
make sure that no pawns get traded
easily on the king so i don't think king
of seven king e6
understood yeah it's just and by the way
uh i just want to bring up the the
hikaru game because yeah
that's one of the ugliest pawn
structures
i've seen in a while well done lavon
yeah the one styling with the shirt he's
got it i mean it's the pawn structure
not only that but you also have the king
on h1 in the rook
yeah this is this is the funkiest
position i've seen in quite some time
you told me we were playing fisher
random at this moment i would believe
you shockingly it's not really that
horrible for white apparently
okay but
but yeah it's uh it's a an oil painting
it really is some kind of an oil
painting well i mean i'm a pond grubber
but boy
grabbing that a pawn and holding to it
in this fashion
yeah it's it's honestly it's amazing i
briefly glanced at the christian screen
there and it says minus 0.1 yeah it's
not that bad did he currently change
shirts on us so he was trying to compete
with lavonne
did he wear that shirt from the first
round definitely didn't win the short
contest no i understand but yes that was
the same shirt okay
hadn't picked up on that
well that would actually have been some
major
uh troll yeah
exactly
looking across the board
chris little john what do i have to do
before the round car well make sure you
have that shirt before right right
yeah i i picked out this great shirt
from your closet you're going to love it
you know the fact i need to have my
coffee and my extra shirt
damn b2 b3 why is it a position
your shirt on your motorcycle yeah right
why isn't this position terrible
christian
i mean it looks terrible because what
are we doing
with from by the way white is a pawn up
yeah true
i understand they're extremely ugly
pawns right you could be considering
that white is actually upon down right
given the structure uh with two double
pawns but why is the pawn up now how do
you attack those ugly pawns
how do you continue okay so if i start
with a stupid move knight g5 just attack
a pawn it's not a stupid move actually
one of the best moves oh sorry yes let's
go i blundered
i'm going to allow you to take on e4
once you take on e4 a lot of light
square diagonals
so finally my bishop gets to do
something
okay
okay
and now suddenly your game has prospects
yes once you take on e4 finally my
bishop gets yeah some pieces for some
pieces actually start making sense for
white here yeah and uh yeah you can you
can sort of imagine why this is not that
horrible yeah i mean yeah
c5 but the a5 i can take on e4 and
knight c5 yeah like why you know
suddenly there's who's better yeah
absolutely no reason for us to be worse
here right queen g3 rook comes out i
mean it's just completely fine i'm
taking white here you have to choose
yeah i think i think i'm thinking white
here you know just a second i'm just
still trying because i've got the rook
coming to eight bishop to d through he
was got the rook coming to a2 i've got i
mean queen on g3 will cover most of
those things i'm pretty sure but you get
there in time yes sir well
i don't know i
so queen h4
queen h4
a2
i can take on e4 what if i take a pawn
and bishop to d3 bishop to f1
[Music]
knight g3 oh knight g3 if you don't mate
me then that's what i heard it's a good
point that you're making i i i'm burning
a lot of bridges uh i i get that i do i
do i really do
um okay uh he did instead
he should not he wants to take on e4
with the bishop okay
yeah absolutely especially with the king
on h1 by the way why not yeah we we
we're not obliged to give it up straight
away right we can play queen h4 for now
i suppose yeah
[Music]
that's your most aggressive piece
you really you really put it out there
beyond the
well not be on the equator but close to
the equator
queen h4 defending e4
wow um
and uh by the way again christian just
help us out bishop to d3 the the engine
approved yes bishop to d3 is just fine
position remains equal or at least
balanced uh in the grand scheme of
things queen two h4 actually allows
black take the initiative after the very
aggressive h6
very aggressive h6 right preparing the
move knight to g5 it makes some sense
you want to uh target this pawn on e4
now if you do go bishop to g4 i just
simply go queen to f7 and i invite you
uh into this situation bishop takes c4
is somehow a tread later on in the game
so bishop to d3 the question is how do
you continue you can go bishop to g4
right now and say that okay you take but
i just simply developed my pieces now
the big problem for the last few moves
was the knight on a4 how do i get it
back in the game because if i go knight
to c3 rook takes a one queen to uh a1
that queen is a bit off uh outside of
play so right now this is the critical
moment bishop to g4 was not played
bishop to f3 is on the board but how do
you answer knight to g5 right now
exactly that's a weird one yeah i don't
i don't know why we are stepping right
right into 90 it doesn't make any sense
you cannot allow knight takes f3 because
then your king is going to be dead or
rook takes f3 as well rule takes f3 is a
big problem as well geez did he just
miss knight to g5 no by the way he's not
yet on the board
well you have to assume this is the plan
right right otherwise bishop d3 makes no
sense it makes very little sense yet
right so quinto d1 d1
this is what he missed
there's a there's a check mate right
right
right there and i'm wondering what if i
just simply go rook to a2
queen to b5 hmm
and it does give a tremendous advantage
uh maybe five is nice but i i also like
i like the second best move better queen
e6 with the idea of knight gt yeah this
is very nice very nice very nice so for
example if you just let me take the
bishop take the bishop yeah you can take
on d3 take on d3 sure and then and then
you get mated yeah well yeah very nice
this is very cute yeah
queen takes h5 um he did not play knight
to g5 yet 10 minutes before he has uh he
has he just played knight he just played
knight
and there you have it i think it
probably is quinji one otherwise like
the whole thing just doesn't make any
sense
i think
if you're not planning to reply with
queen d1 here you never play bishop you
have to play queen d1 yeah and he he
was even worse because
94
he was just take knight c3 yeah
wow i think he's playing
take play knight c3 and claim that you
know bad things had to happen but bad
things did not really have to happen
this is the confusing bit
like he's sort of accepting he will be
worse when he did not
absolutely have to accept he will be
yours
fabi is uh worse he's probably he's a
partner and this bishop's of opposite
color
uh very uh
in the meantime
has completely blown up this is the one
this is the one that we probably need to
take i'm just checking take a look at me
this is the is this the full ugly no no
it's uh they went along sort of the uh
the general outline of what we were
expecting with b4 b5 coming and and sam
in investing in the plan of breaking the
entire thing up with c7 c6 right
and he played c6 bc knight takes a6 and
alireza
went for some tactics
hoping to use the fact i guess the black
is slightly uh discoordinated now and
the knight on a6 is a bit out of play
but i don't see the immediate follow-up
i wonder what he means after queen g7
takes takes like what they because if
you give black a couple of tempe here
black was
very very easily consolidated guys guys
knight takes c4 bishop takes c4
knight to c5 was played which is a huge
blunder
with levon and back to the levon game
because
there's oh there's mate in the end there
queen of five kind of
i mean
you you can't take only four and if you
can't take only four nights knight c5
makes no sense which is why i guess he
like knight c3 was probably
exactly so queen to f5 knight takes c4
rook takes a one is a problem yeah
if you take on eight i take back with
the bishop and then you're going to you
can even you can even play queen f7 i
guess right una5 isn't even obligatory
you can play queen f7 with a very
similar idea yes
yes absolutely you can also just simply
take on a1 and then
to start
97 rook ff1
and that's it
oh yeah this is just winning yeah
because after qf7 at least we can take
on a8 and we can continue the game like
we were lost but we continue the game
here you can't even continue queen f2
but you're going to lose that end game
yeah that game is not very promising
maybe yeah
we take on g2 with the rook and yeah the
dead end game doesn't look very
complicated
that bishop only fought
for yeah i don't think calling it i
don't think calling is an end game is
very fair to be honest i recall at the
end of the game probably the best thing
you can do at that point is go knight f6
rules uh
so this is already car yeah okay well
okay one is just winning because if you
have to play rook takes a one then both
queen of fights it's not the only move
queen five is also completely just
winning right yeah i believe he is
playing what is he doing five yeah he's
playing a fight i think c4 knight takes
e4
yeah
what is he doing yeah is kind of
confused because he thinks like there's
no way leon has missed this but levon
has missed this yeah quite clearly or
maybe he's just kind of done with the
game what
rook takes a one yeah
resignation
oh my goodness yeah and this is sort of
back to the subject of do you play do
you play for you know
against the mark who is on zero out of
two no
no no no
i don't think mark yeah i don't think
this is what happened i'm pretty sure
everyone just got outplayed but right
like it just like nobody nobody really
cares how many points hicaro has he
carries hikaru
uh by the way uh just quickly uh going
to the mdl game this was the open
spanish
that we're we had kind of discussed how
the open spanish falls in and out of
fashion every 20 odd years or so as i
mean it's like the the these
uh cycles you know
and well it's very sharp yeah it's a
very sharp indeed
i'm a bit surprised by a4 specifically
because of the takes a4 that but i guess
maybe he wants to take on a2 yes he does
yes he wants to go like bishop takes a2
or something but it's very very
double-edged i will get a little bit
more i'm not sure i want to know
i'm not sure i'm in love with any of
this i guess it's just time to maybe
just swing the rooks over
i'm not sure which rook i'm swinging
over and i can take on d4
i think and uh like why are we suddenly
abandoning our entire structure there
are no threats after queen of four i
think maybe i think the issue for shock
maybe that he was kind of running on
running short on constructive ideas but
a4 could have been prepared at any time
i think you can play something like
quincy five just as you're indicating
right i don't think you had to commit to
something exactly
um guys one question
please isn't sam shanklin just
completely winning right that's what i
thought yeah i was very much waiting for
you to tell me that i'm wrong for some
reason no no i mean
you can play knight to c5 that's the
easy way out but if you do find the move
knight to b8
which is very attractive just simply
think it's over because knight takes c6
is coming and if i manage to land the
knight on d4 in a good version
it's over exactly nothing to discuss
i
know knight b8 is not a difficult move
to spot either no i mean uh also the
time situation favors uh black sam
shanklin with nine minutes uh alireza
only six minutes definitely struggling
in this game
wow as he came into this game uh two for
two ali ray's uh leading the tournament
yeah i think for for him maybe he got so
slightly over excited
yeah yeah at the prospect of bishop he's
seven
and by the way sam is not having a bad
event if he wins this one he equalizes
alireza he drew his first two games
right
but bishop e7 wait a minute that invites
all kinds of crazy nonsense doesn't it
the e5 is hanging you're using another
pawn yeah and yeah this might be an
important yeah he's still doing fine but
yeah it doesn't feel like he's trying to
maximize i'm assuming he's taking him
with the bishop
and i was going to take this guy yeah
i assume we're taking this guy well 94
wins material you can't undo that at all
but i mean we take only five we go
bishop c7 i suppose put the knight on c5
next okay
yeah we're still doing fine with black
here i'm pretty sure but maybe i
shouldn't have allowed k1 maybe i should
play knight c5 first to have a7 a5 and
go knight c5 here
and by the way it does seem like fabiano
has managed to probably equalize yeah
bobby is fabulous
he equalized yes
wow um
equalized still upon down there's not
much you can do with black okay
i i just do i have too much activity
king to d4 king is coming to c4 b4
there's no way you make any progress
yeah it's just like your pieces are so
completely hamstrung and like all the
bishop endings will be completely drawn
so you
you you can't really come in you know in
in any contact with the enemy here so to
speak like yeah your knight on d7 is
safe but the moment you move it
somewhere and if you go knight to f8 i
go king c4 king before and i pick up the
uh yeah it feels like five people should
be you should maybe
king to c5 yeah i think
the tempo yeah
king c5 bishop back and b4 yeah i can
give you the g4 pawn probably mm-hmm i
don't even know there's also
an argument for playing uh
yeah no not not after night of fate but
i was wondering
if we could have played g5 on the
previous move even instead of bishop d6
i was looking at g5
at once just so yeah just to continue uh
trading down by the way he has tried
knight
yeah not to play bishop d7 f8
is on the board he didn't go king c5 he
went king c4 yeah so that 96 is not the
check i think i can very much relate to
this
uh bishop d7 probably will be the try
and now you can play g5 i assume
makes sense
did you actually going into that
variation uh knight to f8 king c4 bishop
to d7 or f5 and honestly
f5 looks kind of logical here f5 makes
the most sense yeah f5 just because
we're not really very afraid of those
you know one against zero
when we get zero
i don't think you are
yeah the knight on the fate is
so stupid like i mean gfgf knight h7 i
guess but we can just go king before
knight takes a4 we really aren't afraid
of very much and no no no no no no
no this is over okay um
back to ali reza's uh position uh he did
take on d8 bishop and bishop takes d8
and we're expecting that in case of
queen e5
queen e5 and knight c5 as you indicated
probably it's very very that is probably
the plan promising you have a past eight
pawn after
yeah it doesn't look like the harshest
uh you know the most
the
dangerous try for sam could have chosen
but you're still very much fighting for
survival here with white exactly
yeah the move bishop bishop to e7 just
so what if i just simply pick up the
pawn on e5 how do you continue in that
position
yes this is what we're discussing
yeah take stakes yeah i think you take
c5 oh you were you were planning to take
with the with the with the knight
bishop f6 was a four and then f4 yeah
and then the knight will go back to b8
and
yeah thanks take and yeah this is the
one we're discussing for some reason we
were also just as early as i did we were
only really calculating this one i like
knight c5 the best here i think
stop like not stopping but making rook
a1 kind of
ineffective because a5 is a very
comfortable reply it's a good idea rugby
bishop c7 also doesn't seem to be doing
very much for white
somehow it's uh
it's tough to just leave the pawn on
c6 the visual c7 just does such a good
job completely completely blocking
defending yeah yeah so if i go rook d1
bishop c7 knight d7 how do you continue
i think i ignore it i think i wanted to
go king of seven
no there is e4
yeah do you want to take that
and just play two bishops
two bishops versus the rook it's not
much of an
e5 he's got knight b4 which is yeah
okay
he's playing very concretely he's trying
to you know put some pressure on the c6
what if i go look to b1
he wants to play a5 for sure he
definitely
he'd love to get in the move a5 and
bishop c7
so rook b1 will be
actually helpful
yeah yeah
i like it i like uh i like knight b4
it's not bad at all yeah it's not bad at
all
yeah he will just put the bishop on c7
and start pushing his a pawn nobody like
i mean that's not fair to generalize so
much but he's not going to be taking on
e5 until it wins basically like you're
exactly you're only doing it when it's
fully prepared and and wins everything
right
until that moment the bishop stays on c7
just doing doing his blockading job and
not really getting distracted by any
other
in fact this is uh the more i'm looking
at this position it's so it's it's all
play on one goal uh peter is
i don't even see how uh ali raza can
yeah
this is basically you you start looking
for desperado moves yeah i'm not sure
how this improves our channel no i'm
taking this you're taking i think i'm
taking
yeah you don't like two connectors past
bombs
i think it's maybe slightly over over
you were telling me the bishop on c7 is
so good
yeah i'm worried about rugby 1d6
rook d1 and rook d6 okay that's kind of
cool uh even though
my problem is i think it can be ignored
what if i just take
yeah also that but i was kind of my
problem was i couldn't really figure out
what to do against bishop c8
like dc just continue grabbing stuff
yeah why why are we not just winning
more material
bishop maybe he wants to go up knight to
d7 or rook to d1 and knight to d7
let's go rook d1 rogue one bishop c7 97
i mistrust uh yeah he wants like the six
knight g5 in some positions i guess yeah
knight f6 knight d5
well that will not work
my point is i want to play c4 i want to
say yeah i want to say i want to say i
have passers i want to push let's go
write c5 no i want to go knight c5 he's
gone b5 okay interesting so
by the way jeffrey seems to be building
up quite a tremendous advantage against
dominguez with the black pieces yeah
uh just coming off of the victory it's
just over because queen to d3 is coming
right and after king g1
e3
that oh yeah that just wins yeah of
course
i missed i miss rook takes a five in the
end there yeah something has gone badly
wrong therefore for for lanier he has
kind of failed to to control the
the sudden counter play and kung g4
so queen d3 king to g1 e3 yeah this is
he probably this is what he missed he
thought he was still sort of doing okay
because if you take on g5 i take on f2
you cannot go king to h1 because of f1
if you take on f2 rook takes f5 wins
yeah that's
that's very likely that's very likely
what he missed here just just the movie
e4 e3 there
yeah big moment right now if jeffrey
finds this one and jeffrey is actually
on one victory and one draw exactly
might actually uh take him into a clear
first and remember this video
if ali reza loses
no bishop to c1 whoa there's another way
of skinning this cat yeah very very fpsc
this is wait a minute what
wait a minute oh the queen is still on
d4
i was about to say there's a mate on g7
no queen d3 yet no queen d3 uh
bishop c1 immediately
by the way i have to say i like that
move too it's a very it's a very cute
move and it also loses uh its own
advantage what its whole advantage is
but only because of yeah i also briefly
kind of cheated by glancing at what the
engine suggests the only move in this
position is not very easy to make
apparently by far the best move in the
position is the move rook f7
which looks like f7 yeah
jump to mine
yes but f6 is also move
yes what
still followed with the idea of quick
queen f6 rook f7 rook f7 yeah this is
this is the key good f6 threatening mate
and you've got rook f7
and by the way he has to solve
this puzzle with only 30 seconds on his
yeah i think i think in proxy also he is
still in tremendous amounts of trouble
but
so you're inviting queen takes b2 as
well
geez
my gosh well queen to b2 i think i have
rook to b1
like the line very much continues
but i just won two pawns
yeah he found it but he didn't play f6
he played rook have seven which is
that's the best that's the best move
okay
and now f6 is a huge threat he like
bishop takes b2 fc no then that doesn't
work okay bishop takes b2 i guess from
d1 first and then f6
why doesn't f6 work queen d3 and bishop
xf6
very nice
that's actually worth
putting on uh
on our show bishop takes b2 for a second
there i thought f6 just wins the game
here for white but unfortunately a queen
d3 check frees up the diagonal for the
bishop and the bishop gets back to
just protect everything in the nick of
time so you have to start with rook to d
yeah we start with rosie one
instead of f6 yeah instead of yeah we go
rogue d1 and take away uh
the d3 squared as a tempo
and we we we're just kind of stabilizing
we've lost some material but even if we
have to play something like bishop b6
here we're just not doing so poorly
because the bishop eventually will fall
back to d5 and we have compensation the
king on f1 is suddenly completely safe
it cannot really be checked even we're
controlling all the squares from which
black can give a check by the way guys
ali reza is back in the game
really in the variation that we were
actually looking at
he did not find bishop to c8 he got
greedy like i did he took on d6 and that
actually is just a draw he could have
played bishop c8 and just left
everything hanging a draw is the wrong
one it's still a balanced position right
now from an objective point of view
yeah bishop c8 is uh
it's ridiculous yeah
and now f5 yeah and i think what sam
understood correctly is that white
currently has no way to make progress
but what he didn't understand what i
also didn't understand is that why can
actually play f4 g4 and create a huge
threat of f45 by the way
this is ridiculous isn't it easier to
play with sort of yes yeah i think it is
yeah
well wait a minute like sam might
actually be in trouble well he is
why is why is this
f5 a threat so if i go a5 a4 yeah a4
forward me let's go i5 f5 i take it
let's say yeah
and i go back and just sub d seven and i
take it she thinks
oh now you want f6 suddenly yeah
this is a queen shoot this is just a
queen oh shoot by the way oh shoot yeah
so i have to go knight takes c6
well you have to take on c6 before a4 a3
in fact it's the only move no no no this
is already i think bad
for some reason this looks like a draw
after no no i think it's a draw of that
this is d7a1 king somewhere probably is
just a draw
because i don't think you ever have
anything stronger than a perpetual here
you pretty pretty clearly will have a
perpetual okay actually it's not f5
after a4 c7 wins
after f after a4 cc7
yeah so you have to defend against d7
king e8 f5 and then f6 f7 d7 the problem
is that after c7 knight a6 d7 bishop
takes d7 i take on g7 with a check you
don't have time to take on c7 oh my
goodness
oh my goodness that's crazy
yeah
knight ac6 the only move in the position
right now to save sam shanklin
knight takes c6 he has to do it right
away yeah knight 696 a4
and start pushing and and then himself
yeah and then he survives
what a swing that was just huge but to
but to take on d6 in that ugly position
where black white blondes are so well
known
apparently playing bishop c8 there it's
just uh that's a mystery and actually
let's go through the variations after
knight c6 because they're just simply
wild okay what are the variations not a4
knight takes c6 and b six first yep i
take on c6 back and forth take that a4
f5
a4 f5 yes a3
yes
take on e6 yes
a to d7
yes and now after a1 i will not have
anything better by the perpetual no this
is the very similar situation to the one
we just right we just had i i had traded
off the g pawn you can do that as well
yeah because i was thinking queen g7
check might be useful one day but
this is remarkable
yeah this is this is by the way and he's
done it he recognized one question how
easy is the perpetual here
so let's go king g2
or king f2 sure
king g2 okay
b2 king g3 or king c3 no i don't think
it's difficult yeah we always have
finished six queen of six oh you have
queen enough
six i always have enough yeah
and by the way if you do get a situation
like this
it might not be the perpetual you want
i mean you can queen the pawn oh but uh
we do have a draw yeah probably if i be
saved that game but he's uh
not happy with the white
with this play with the white pieces so
this game between uh he did they called
c6 by the way sam so that's yeah no that
was a great move that was uh
and i mean for me the big question right
now is why can't we play bishop d7
like why are we uh
so completely obliged to start panicking
yeah like why why come to go bishop d7
not before king f7 king f6 king e5 king
king takes g6
i guess we're just not better because
the king will get to e3 and then d4 and
11 before is a very nice blockading
piece
so we probably just like we're supposed
to take that draw while it's available i
guess it's the answer
we're just not better so
like there's currently an immediate
force draw available and we should be
taking it yeah bishop bishop d7 is the
move um
now let's look into f2
and i think what oh sorry not f6
immediately so so bishop d7 knight to b4
yeah gfgf already has been included so
let's just put it on the board yeah okay
gf gf sorry
gfgf yep
we should be seven knight before king of
seven
yeah can you just looking at 16 e3 this
is okay
yeah he wants to make a draw yeah this
will be a draw he wants to make a draw
yeah
e7 makes no sense he seven king eight
you probably lose so he goes d7 yeah sam
gives a check and yeah
this setup with the pawn on d7 protected
by the pawn on e6 is quite clearly
completely unshakable so right you can't
lose but you also can't win because the
king the queen on the completely open
board never runs out of checks
now sam
must not be happy with this result
because it felt like he was actually
without a very long time without the g
pawns by the way they can go like i can
go g3 now yes king c3 king g4
queen g7 king f5
that's a problem
actually without those pawns this is
actually trickier like way trickier
because i have this f5 square i can use
to try to get to like c7 my my eventual
target is like a c7 square over there
about you know uh the queen c3
the the king g4 yeah
yeah
we have to go king king g4 yeah if
oh my goodness
yeah we're being told kg4 is just
winning on the spot
are you kidding me sam thinks is a draw
but after king g4
no no he doesn't know he definitely
doesn't know that he is lost
by the way why is queen f6
let's see sam's reaction right now
because why is queen f6 losing
you queen the pawn i assume
yeah
i take it
he's starting to understand right yeah
he said he's in trouble
e7 czech
king eight 897.96 knight c4
whoops oh shoot
he's done
this is actually quite easy ali reza is
going to go on three
oh my goodness
and the crazy so apparently quincy three
was a mystery so what was he supposed to
play instead of queen c3
instead of queen to c3 queen to f6 was
the only move and then after king
ah g4 queen g6 and you don't have oh
yeah we can't so yeah we we we
absolutely have to give a check from g6
exactly let's see the sam's reaction
right now because i'm i'm very curious
he was exactly a minute right now he was
expecting a perpetual yeah he was
expecting the king to go back and the
king is not really going back going back
now
oh my goodness
h5 okay it doesn't matter we're looking
at five anyway
i'm pretty sure yeah
yeah he we're good
h5 even what
blunder
blender alert yes
minus 60
it's not no no
black is winning after queen takes c6
guys queen takes c6 d8 queen to e8
exchange the queens and the b pawn is
unstoppable why do you
why do you play king takes h5
f5 what is your interest in that pawn
like why why do you even like what guys
if he finds queen takes c6 he's gonna
find it because he's gonna see his
winning queen e8 check
that is just
this is wild i this is wireless i mean
and look sam
is no he does not take it no
queen takes asia that's why we love
rapids
oh my god
incredible i mean this is the hot this
is the hot potato nobody wants to catch
it
okay so where's the draw and this is a
draw i couldn't have to quincy five now
yeah
oh my god
glad we got rid of the h-pawns right
now it's a very trivial draw because it
doesn't get too it doesn't get to
d6 or any of those squares yes wonderful
uh
that was a moment where everybody's uh
heart just stopped
and curiosity valley reza saw it yeah
that's that's the big question there
yeah the big question is i mean sam
clearly didn't see it but you have to
because i was watching alireza very
carefully and he didn't seem like he was
worried
mm-hmm
maybe yeah it's just it's just a draw
now yeah so the question is yeah how
good how good is his poker face there
because yeah this is uh
this is quite something
yeah queen six
whoa
whoa
what's happening there yeah they will
return yeah
there's a a
yeah and jeffrey zhang versus uh yeah he
said he said yeah
he is
like mvl is also winning against the
shack
it's the two rooks versus the two queens
but there's an extra
couple of pawns for the rooks as well
this should be easy win now
dominguez versus jeffrey is going to end
up in a draw
that one is quite clear right now
okay we might still get another decisive
result that is mvl let's stay with that
one
and again uh
i'm recalling uh the the match between
peter lico and uh vladimir kramnik where
the rooks overcame
uh the queen
in that match
herself yeah but the position was lost
but yes king h6 is unnecessary
and we that leaves us with one remaining
which will be a draw because yeah this
is a very well known construction you're
waiting for white to play five and then
you play with seven and you stay only
seven and d8 squares forever and uh keep
the pawn on g5 and you're locked bishop
yeah you're yeah
this diagonal is just long enough to
yeah
for this to be a draw yeah any further
and you're and you're lost but uh this
is just long enough to
uh to be addressed
also yeah
so a lot of a lot of swings uh in the
round yeah jeffrey was winning in one
move at some point but christian i i'd
love you to take a take us through that
sam shanklin moment because that's that
that at the end there that was amazing
to me
that
white's a queen up absolutely queen and
queen versus knight and two connected
past pawns but it was white
who was pushing the so at this point
queen to f6 has to be played right and
this is a comfortable droid first of all
leave the g pawns on the board don't
take on f5 but this is not easy to see
from afar actually hang on a second i
wanted to ask you what about king e2
here
king d3 king d3 queen to b3 king d4 king
and then we have this queen c5 check
yeah this is the point yeah it's the
same thing right right and you check all
right
yes once we get this construction on the
board we know that it's a draw okay
queen to c3 huge mistake
king to g4 h5 best move by the way in
the position because it's easy to see
after queen to g7 king to f5 there's
nothing to calculate you're going to
have to resign very soon so h5 good shot
by interviews with
of course queen takes c6 this is just
wild stuff because if you do go d8 queen
to e8 forces the queen trade and i'm
just simply much faster than you are
right so king to g5 for h well not much
faster one two one temperature but it's
enough
much faster that's enough yeah one is
one is enough that's enough it's enough
so he wow
i think what he was looking for was how
to make a draw at this point
was a winning move yes
and after queen to c5 the only movie
five e5 wins if you're looking to f4
queen to f2 that's that's
construction yeah but you have to go e5
and now i
create another path for my king king to
e4 followed by king to d5 and then i
hide behind your pawn king to c5 king to
b6 and so on there's no way you can get
to me anymore if you go queen to c2 i go
king to f6
queen to f2 i go king to g6
queen to g3 and i hide
queen to f4 and i hide queen to f5
suddenly don't have any more checks this
is study like that's a study this is
amazing that's just a study this is a
study that's great stuff
incredible wow no queen to f6
queen to e5 obviously knight takes e5 is
game over there's no way to stop the
eight just an incredible game in an
incredible end game guys okay well
as we get ready for some interviews uh
after the round we first just uh remind
everybody where we stand uh the
results of rapid chess we know that uh
ali reza has five points he came in
with four it's easy to begin to draw
exactly what the the standings are and
what
uh first of all let's take a look at
something else uh opening ceremonies
that took place yesterday it was very
nice by the way peter it was it was uh
very very nicely organized as usual
the the opening ceremonies here are
incredibly on point in that
they are
just as long as they need to be exactly
it was all about for
pulling them drawing the numbers but it
really was more like
hey everybody where you've been what
you've been up to how's it going
uh i thought that jan was actually
entertaining too it was answers
that christian had christian was the
master of ceremonies
and uh rex welcomed everybody as he
always does in his own
initial world fashion
yeah and the
there you see the the drawing of lots
where players had to choose a very
beautiful book as their number for the
rapidem blitz and then a fridge magnet
as their number in the uh
sorry in first in the in the rapid and
then
and the tournament and there's your
there's your standings
with alireza at the top there
for a second yeah
and then there is three people uh uh
with one win and two draws uh mbl who
won his last round game against shah uh
linear with a win in the first round and
then two draws and jeffrey with
one win and two draws as well uh jan and
sam are on three draws out of three so
far and then we have people who are
below 50
yeah but for now an interview
christian with our leader
we do have ali reza in the house already
first of all this is fresh to you right
now tell us a bit about this end of this
wild game
yeah
okay first of all i am very relieved
that he he didn't see the queen c6 did
you see it yeah i saw the move
immediately after i took on h5
so you have a good poker face
that answer
answers our question because we were
considering queen takes e6 and obviously
peter said that he looked at you and you
didn't
show anything no he was very lucky
because normally you think about this
kind of moves
because
he was struggling also that was the
point that maybe because he was
struggling you you see all the moves you
calculate all the moves so i was very
lucky here that
he missed this queen c6 so yeah this is
did you show it to him after a round i
told him but okay he was not also very
upset because it's a it's just it's just
my luck that he got this chance so
absolutely and
did you get this i think how you were
winning after king to f5 yeah i saw the
commentary but uh
before that i think i should have played
maybe more
accurately yes
way before um
i think
instead of g4 i said maybe c7 i have
some chances
c7 here yeah but it's wrong e8 g4
bishop to c8 seems to be one of five
yeah
some sort of a race
knight a6
f6 on knight c7 yeah okay
yeah then g4 is logical so
before that i was losing yeah but then
yeah i got this chance to push my pawns
so but he reacted very accurately also
because it could get tricky for black
so well knight takes e6 right now is the
only only move right yes
and he found it and then you guys yeah i
was lucky in this presentation but did
you see the end of it after king to f5
the way to win this one after check e5
check check you go to h8 yeah this is
insane it's just wild stuff
i had the feeling that this should might
be winning but um i didn't have time to
think about it so
i was always worried that he could um
put the queen on for instance he even
here it's by luck that is winning queen
g5
d8 takes the eight actually is a track
d8 is a draw so you have to go eat that
one first
take something
that doesn't finish so you have 96 and
go back
this is just incredible
i will show this to my students already
this is your first time in st louis how
is the atmosphere in your camp and how
do you feel playing yeah yeah i really
like the city um as i expected i think
the chess club is very nice
and i'm happy to be here for the first
time so
as i said in the open ceremony is kind
of it was my dream from childhood to
play here so
now i'm very happy and i'm looking
forward to this tournament i started
well
my last game was not very precise but
i take it into two and a half out of
threes okay how do you assess your uh
chances obviously after day one is a bit
early but how do you assess your chances
to win the event yeah i think if i
continue playing like this i have good
chances but there are little things that
i should improve but if i manage to
continue like
this way and i have good chances i think
to win the tournament do you feel like
you're in shape right now are you seeing
the things that you should be seeing
yeah i think
okay the last round maybe it was a
victory but the previous games it was
very fresh so i'm happy here already
congratulations we'll see you tomorrow
thank you
oh congratulations too yeah absolutely
well well i love that e7 check yeah that
is then you create the bond you don't
play d8 immediately peter no no i yeah i
think i think
many of these things in that end game
are just completely unfindable in
practical terms in particular on a
minute and
both of them are playing but no that is
really
i can imagine losing on a puzzle rush
you know like
getting a strike with with by playing d8
immediately
you just assume that you've got to
promote the pawn to queen and of course
we've got more uh um
uh interviews uh coming your way
including christian with mvl
we are with maxim vashir lagrav maxim
quite a solid start plus one after uh
three rounds how do you feel
yeah i
obviously didn't play
am i doing my plots for today because
i started with two blacks as three very
tough opponents
so i knew i should expect a tough tough
day first two games were kind of
difficult speaking of that you started
with the qga then you switched to your
uh groomfield how did you make that
decision
i planned to play
to play grenfell but against knight f i
decided to go for qga avoid the
anti-grunfeld in that one yes and you
avoid the so many lines
in the qga
when white goes knight upside that i
thought it was worth it absolutely and
then in the last round you played
against um mahmed yarov how did you
approach this game
i mean i knew that
this
open spanish could happen so i decided
to play solid because i had two
two long games
but then shaq played queen d7 i thought
you would go castle and
this is more solid for black
um and i don't know i felt like i had
the advantage but then i
i waited a bit uh too long like it did
feel like yeah from this position i i
felt like i was yeah bishop b1 i mean
this
is so
so passive yeah king h2 of course
um
bishop b1 is slow and
maybe queen d3 creates some more
problems on this okay when this g6 i
didn't actually want kuni striking g7
because very often i want uh knight h2
f5 so
so i actually didn't want him to to play
g6
but bishop b1 was a bit slow and
then when you feel like you're taking
over or when you feel like he made the
last mistake yeah so later on because my
position was actually not
not that great i thought a4 was uh
quite a mistake actually
so then i took because he cannot really
take any piece because of bishop b5
so after
if he takes on a2 bishop to b5 for
instance yeah yeah
um
and here yeah
a5 i assume was a
good move but
at the same time
i wasn't completely sure because then my
point goes to a6 hispan goes to b3 and
uh it's a race yeah like knight
a6 queen to e4 seems to be the best move
yeah
it is better for me but i thought bishop
if i was safer
and then
then we actually went more or less by
force yeah i wanted to go e6 yeah
and instead of
here
yes
bishop takes c4
yeah is that what you calculated
yeah bishop takes c4 i thought
so
yeah on d7
so rook takes d4
there was some crazy line wait wait yes
here
um i think rook c4 was
a bit
crazy
like queen b5
rook d7 rook d7
rook c8
king h7 if i take with the pawn it
should be a draw so queen f5 g6 queen f6
queen f1
oh oh that's beautiful
that's beautiful king h2 g2 yeah takes
f1 rook to d1
oh that's a shot that's nasty so i was
calculating all this because i thought
afterwards if i would be pressing but
then i had to settle for d7 which i
assume was a draw
because we get by force to this position
at least i'm not running any danger but
i assumed it would be a draw somewhere
and
but then i yeah g5 felt very wrong
i must say
g5 felt like a
like i thought after king g6 for
instance
i mean
perhaps i i mean i was going to try like
play hockey
before but i assume i never can manage
to create something and then uh when
suddenly i get my rook to f3 and i'm
winning the f7 pawn by force
i mean might still be a draw but
uh it looks already very scary yeah
queen to d1 is maybe yeah i thought g5
just helped me tremendously because
there's never perpetual
and we all congratulations a good start
for you good luck tomorrow thank you
christian
thank you christian and uh indeed uh
nice a nice day for mvl yeah he had good
good good good feelings at the party
yeah and uh
to to spot a line like that queen
it shows that
it shows that yeah the cobwebs are
the cobs webs are well well and truly
cleared by that point if you say that uh
live live and in-game so to speak
exactly very very
very very sharp calculator of course
truth be told i'm still recovering from
e7 check yes
that was uh
amazing
amazing uh
today
and uh let's return to christian as we
have a new guest uh jeffy zhang with
christian jeffrey congratulations a very
good start for you especially that game
that victory against fabiano
you were blitzing out through the
opening moves how much did you know
yeah i think i
i definitely knew this idea with um with
knight d4 in rook d1
and i think i remember it's still fine
for him
but he has to find
uh it's a very difficult move yeah
it does work yeah bishop h3
so you knew about this move you've
analyzed it well i know that the engine
still showed its equal um i didn't delve
into the lines but
but yeah this makes sense and i guess
besides bishop h3 maybe
i mean uh instead of a space three for
black he doesn't have another way to
equalize no no knight to c6 but
allowing this is not very happy yeah
when i can get the two bishops open yeah
it should be quite pleasant
and after that there was another
critical moment all the way until the
end
you played this move not even here all
the way i think it was
let's keep going
bishop to c3 yes you got your pawn all
the way to h6
bishop to c2 king to g7 and now rook to
d3 ah yeah yeah i i definitely wonder
this idea would you spot this move no no
um i didn't see his id in the game
either
yeah he did mention this to me and
it was yeah kind of uh f7 doesn't work
because of rook to d7 and h7 the same
and after bishop to b2 just check you go
to h8 check or bishop to d3 and if you
do go uh rook to g8 you simply look to
d7
while stuff in this one he did not find
it big victory for you against fabiano a
customer you know so well because you
guys also had a huge battle at the
american cup how did that victory feel
for you
well yeah i mean i think
any win in this tournament is is very
nice
but yeah i guess the slight revenge from
that match
uh was a bonus
and then in the last one against
dominguez it felt like you're building
up quite a
serious advantage did you feel that way
as well
yeah i think
especially when he was getting really
low on time and i got an e4 i felt like
looked extremely promising for me but
somewhere i think maybe i got too fancy
with uh with bishop c1
and you had this
moment ago queen to d3 followed by e3
yeah i i didn't notice this i
oh i forgot okay i forgot i have a rook
f5 okay
yeah it's just oh yeah this was a was a
big miss i guess and after bishop to c1
he managed to find this move rook to f7
which actually just equalizes the game
on the spot
jeffrey still a very good result for you
how do you feel about your chances in
this tournament what is the goal for
this tournament
i wouldn't say that i'm thinking about
that i think it's still very early so
just trying to
to play as well as i can and see what
results i get
congratulations jeffrey we'll see you
tomorrow yeah we'll play jeffrey well
played indeed absolutely and uh for jeff
these uh wild card players i'm waiting
for him to become a
grand chess tour participant i want to
see him in the scene i think every time
every time he plays uh uh
jeffrey has a very very solid showing
and you know we we all know how strong
he is exactly um and once again for uh
those who joining us very late here are
our standings after three
uh rounds of play peter alireza at the
top there winning the first two and then
drawing that absolutely wild game
against sam shanklin in round three uh
three people on four out of six uh mbl
lanier and uh jeffrey then jan and sam
shanklin on three out of three draws
right and four people uh below fifty
percent uh including fabi livon
surprisingly and and hikaru and
starting with two uh losses was my pick
and uh the farouzia fans are going
cheering uh themselves wild
yeah it's you know plenty plenty of
action to to to come we still have let's
talk about that tomorrow same time same
channel absolutely round four through
six four four five six yes absolutely
yeah three more rounds of rapid tomorrow
three more rounds of rapid day after
tomorrow and then uh two full round
robins of blitz on monday and tuesday
plenty of action to come so yes continue
we'll be here continue watching please
exactly and
christian final thoughts on a very
eventful uh start to the
st louis rapid and blitz well i have to
say guys if uh we would have watched
only one game in the first three rounds
i would have been happy with that
ferruja shankling game forget about
all the others but we had so much
content in all the others as well it was
just a fantastic wild game of rapid
trust and this is exactly what we signed
up for so i'm very excited to what the
future holds in the next few days
couldn't say better myself and uh thank
you everyone for joining us we'll see
you all tomorrow see you then
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you